Bill thank you madam
chair uh Mr Clark I have a I do have a
copy of my testimony uh honorable me
members for the record um representative
Pat long representing Hillsboro district
10 in Manchester House Bill 1465 is an
attempt in clarifying language in RSA
169b specifically that the court shall
presume
indigency subject to the Court's
reconsideration once all the information
on the Minor's Financial ability is
available further states that the
appointment of council shall remain in
effect until the court no longer has
jurisdiction puru pursuant to this
chapter the bill also clarifies that the
council can be used in
substantively related to the child's
delinquency
proceedings uh finally clarifies with
certainty that the Juvenile and or their
parents are Guardian shall not be
responsible for costs associated with
the appoint attorney uh and in the past
this committee has agreed with the
benefits of appointments of an attorney
and juvenile petitions and I ask for
your support on House Bill 1465 and
clarifying our attent thank you madam
chair thank you very much are there any
question questions for representative
long Madam chair yes um thank you
representative long I appreciate you
being here today and putting this bill
in was this similar to the bill that was
put in last
session uh thank thank you for the
question representative uh it it is uh
the dark the uh bolded areas are what's
being added to what was uh uh what was
passed so that that's all the Bold areas
are what's different from what was
originally
passed so mik my question I I think you
know my concern is um the cons the the
appointment of an attorney for
other um
issues related to the child's
proceedings um so I do have some
concerns over that yeah yeah I thank you
thank you uh Madam chair I I uh I
believe the substantively related uh to
the child's delinquency I I think we may
need to um identify what those are uh
because it does open it up to a wide
range you know you know we we spoke of
the um example of I'm I'm the juvenile I
I punched the kid at my school and they
lost the tooth and I'm in civil court
for uh paying for the tooth
and I don't know if we want the state to
be paying for the attorney in that civil
suit so right so yeah I would agree that
maybe maybe a more of a definition of
what
substantially uh
ated are there any further questions for
representative
long okay seeing none thank you so much
you okay up next is Mike Skiby with the
disability right center and he's asked
for five to 10 minutes to speak in
support of the
bill and do you have written
testimony okay thank
you
is the mic
on there you go how's that so I've given
uh representative Banger two handouts
one is a table that compares last year's
bill with this year's Bill and then I've
also given a copy of this year of last
year's bill but just one copy for the
clerk to have in the folder so that you
if anybody wants to reference it they
can um included with the bill is the
amendment that was passed by the
committee as well as the docket sheet so
you can just sort of see what happened
to the bill last year okay great
representative bang could you pass those
around
please so my name is Michael skibby um
I'm from the disability rights Center of
New Hampshire
um with regard to this bill um we are
part of a coalition of organizations
that have advocated over the years for
reform of the juvenile justice system in
New Hampshire other members include the
youth law project of New Hampshire legal
assistance the ACLU new Futures and
Waypoint the purpose of this bill is to
improve the legal representation of
children in the delinquency system in
several ways first through protecting
their right to counsel during police
questioning secondly through making the
appointment of councel earlier in the
process third through ensuring that the
involvement of council continues until
the Court's Jurisdiction has concluded
and then fourth ensuring that Council
can protect the child's interests when
there are multiple proceedings going on
at the same time with regard to the
conduct that the child is charged with
um obviously this bill concerns those
most vulnerable in our court system
that's true of all children but children
who are court involved have a very high
level of disability as compared to the
population at large and they're often
from families that are dealing with many
challenges including poverty that sort
of put the family and the child at
greater risk um in the court system and
elsewhere it's important that these
children receive the assistance they
need to be able to navigate the system
that could result in the loss or
restriction of their Liberty we have a
system that rightly or wrongly has
imposed the adversarial nature of the
adult criminal justice system on the
juvenile justice system with all of its
advantages and disadvantages for an
adversarial system to work as designed
both sides have to must have the ability
and resources necessary to gather
evidence make presentations to the court
challenge inaccurate or improperly um
collected information um and in the case
of a child in the juvenile justice
system to raise challenges to whether
the rules are really being followed um
in the system
itself um in our system that requires
the assistance of competent councel
throughout the proceedings if I think
the result of this legislation will be
Improv fairness in the system better
confidence in the results of that system
and a better alignment of services and
interventions with the actual needs of
Children and Families and along the
lines I think it will be a better use of
limited public resources this
legislation like last year's legislation
follows the publication of an extensive
report um by the national juvenile
Defender Center on the uh system for
providing represent representation to
children in New Hampshire National
experts conducted a comprehensive review
of our system and made a variety of
recommendations to bring it up to the
standards necessary to make the system
fair for our
children uh last year there was a
another bill House Bill 188 and I don't
want to truncate your consideration but
I thought it would be helpful today to
focus in on those things that are
different from what you U what you
approved of last year um and that is why
I prepared the table that is before you
on the left is the the sections of
today's Bill and on the right are the
corresponding sections um in last year's
bill um I think that um hopefully it
will allow you to focus on those issues
that resulted in last year's bill being
placed on the table and then eventually
dying um on the table um I think that
the the modifications that we made this
year have addressed most if not all of
the ISS I don't think they've addressed
all the issues but they've addressed
most of the issues that were the focus
of that floor action um so if you look
at the table you'll see
that um starting at the top that um the
determination of financial ability to
pay um has been um has been modified so
that the existing requirement that a
lawyer be appointed immediately upon the
case beginning is not delayed by this
process that the courts go through to to
see if someone can afford Council so it
basically says to the court go ahead and
appoint counsel you can deal with the
ability to pay later and then make an
adjustment if necessary and so that's
that's similar to a corresponding
section that we had last year um in the
the second part of section one of this
bill um also requires that a that a
lawyer remain available to the child
while the court has jurisdiction over
the child it's that's that's very
similar to a section that we had in 188
last year there was one limitation that
the drafters last year put in there
saying that although not in situations
where the only remaining issue involves
the payment of fin or
restitution I think that um as long as
the court has jurisdiction over the
child I think that a child that a child
should be able to reach out to the
lawyer and ask for assistance in any
ongoing Court proceedings regardless of
what they may uh deal with because they
could conceivably result in an extension
of jurisdiction probation or some uh
manner of loss of Liberty
um this um this section also deals with
the question that you had uh Madam chair
about when someone can when a lawyer for
a child can be involved in related
proceedings and th this is pretty
significantly changed last year it it
was the language was when um when such
matters are based on the same factual
circumstances as the petition without
any requirement that there be a
necessity that involvement in those
other
proceedings is required to to
appropriately represent the child in the
juvenile proceedings so that I think
last year's language did raise the
question understandably that if there's
a a lawsuit for money damages that
arises out of a fight and a lost tooth
is it appropriate really for that lawyer
to become involved in that civil suit
for damages what this what this language
is doing is is emphasizing that there
must be some Nexus between that other
proceeding so that it's involvement in
some way and maybe only showing up and
telling the child not to talk about what
happened while the other case is pending
for example or it may involve you know
observing someone else's testimony about
the same the same transaction so that
you can better prepare for the juvenile
case there needs to be that kind of
Nexus under the language that is in the
bill before you and Michelle wangren who
is from thehab your legal assistance
will talk in more detail about the
related proceedings uh provisions
um section two talks about protections
against the use of statements by
children to police officers or those who
are working closely with police officers
such as school officials investigating
something that happened at the school it
limits the availability of the results
of those kinds of questioning
circumstances against a child when they
don't have access to counsel now last
year there was a similar Pro a similar
um uh provision but it was much more
unlimited than this one is this is
basically focused on questioning by
police or those who are working closely
with the police under circumstances
where a child believes that they have to
respond to questions or that they're not
free to leave and that's the language in
section two of the bill now last year it
was much more wide- ranging it basically
said any question any statement by a
child regardless of who it was made to
what the circumstances were whether the
child felt as though they had to speak
or not so this is Much More Much More
constrained and much more focused on the
problem that that always exists when
someone who is
vulnerable um is confronted with an
authority authority figure particularly
a police officer um and uh asked to
respond to questions so that's a
significant change um section three is
essentially identical to last year which
involves removing the obligation to
repay the cost of appointed counsel um
the remaining sections also address the
same thing although it sort of picks up
some related uh Provisions that are
sprinkled throughout uh our statute to
make sure that that it's clear that the
bill as a whole is removing the
obligation to repay the cost to counsel
by a child or their family
so I hope that that is helpful in terms
of allowing you to focus on the
distinctions between last year's Bill
and this year's bill I think I would
just want to spend a moment or two more
on the issue of uh the questioning uh by
police officers in section two um so
obviously you know we're talking about
children um uh in encounters with
authority figures now our law for more
than half a century has recognized that
even adults have a difficult time
dealing with the inherently coercive
nature of police interrogation and
that's why we have the Miranda warnings
that have been part of our law since the
1960s um you know police uh fully
capable adults it need to be warned that
they have a right to uh remain silent
and to ask for a lawyer regardless of
whether they're children or have
disabilities in the case of children
obviously um you know it goes uh I think
it's common sense and it also the
research also shows that children are
much more susceptible to police
interrogation tactics than adults
they're inherently less equipped to
resist the demands of an authority
figure children by their nature are more
focused on short-term reward rather than
long-term consequences
any of us who are parents can recognize
that and based on our experience of
dealing with children's Behavior this
would have impacts to judicial processes
we would ask that the effective date be
modified to January 1
2022 um and then finally just with again
with regard to section two um and this
is not a a position on the bill but
simply an observation that if Council
needs to be appointed through this
process of the law en enforcement filing
a petition that would not be available
uh nights weekends or holidays it's a
it's a during the day uh type of
petition um and then as also as noted in
the fiscal fiscal note for the judicial
councel there is
a significant shortage of council these
days um and I'm not sure how this would
play into the availability of council to
perform these duties um but again we
don't have a position on it but simply
an observation relative to both when
these petitions would be ruled upon how
quickly they might get ruled upon and
the availability of council with that
I'd be happy to take any questions if
anyone has any great thank you any
questions representative Banger thank
you madam chair
um you said you want the effective de
and thank you for being here today um I
appreciate it um you said you want the
effective to be January 1st
2022 2023 sorry okay I just wanted to
clarify thank you I was wondering why it
was back da no my fault thank you very
much for pointing that out this is what
I shouldn't do it night before
understand I feel you thank you for
pointing out no further questions okay
thank
you I just need you to turn off your mic
yeah there we go okay are there any
further questions for Mr head all right
thank you very much thank
you all right up next is Michelle
wangren from the new Hampshire legal
assistance to speak in support of the
bill and she's asked for 10
minutes hi hi good morning honorable
chair and members of the commission
committee um so as attorney Skiby um
said earlier I have a couple of things
that I would like to address really
focusing in on a couple of different
areas of the bill um as most of you know
I was involved in HB 188 last year and
provided extensive testimony at that
time in support of the bill as well and
we hope that the Amendments that um 1465
make address many of the concerns that
the committee had or not so much the
committee but the full house had last
year um as all of you likely remember
this committee actually passed um 188
out with an aut toass recommendation and
then there were concerns raised on the
floor so we're really hoping that these
amendments get to those concerns and I'm
happy to run through through some
specifics on how I think that they do um
so first of all I just want to focus in
on part um 1A of section one that
discusses the representation at
ancillary proceedings and postd
dispositional
representation um I'll start by honing
in on that post-d dispositional
representation and the continuity of
council throughout the the life of a
juvenile delinquency case um we think
that that is just simply good policy
it's something that when the pandemic
hit uh there were many Advocates who
were very concerned that after a child
is
um receives a disposition or a sentence
in a juvenile proceeding they could be
returned to home or they could be placed
out of home and typically what happens
in those cases is that their defense
attorney will close their case and then
may reopen it 30 days before their next
hearing and during that time they're
without represent ation so when the
pandemic hit um there were a lot of
folks who were very concerned that
children who were in out of home
placements um and not having access to
home visits or um you know other other
um contact with life outside of these
placements that they needed an advocate
and this was really widely agreed upon
by um the judicial Council and by um
defense attorneys and prosecutors and so
everyone just sort of agreed that yes it
makes sense to allow postd dispositional
advocacy for these kids and that their
um their attorneys should remain in
place throughout the life of at least
their out of home placement um we think
that makes sense for a number of reasons
um at these placements kids are um wi
without their family without their
friends without eyes on them there are
Staffing shortages we have very very
high rates of restraint seclusion in
these facilities um as a an education
practitioner what I often um encounter
is kids um who have IEPs or special
education services and then they wind up
in a placement and those placements
don't offer their special education
services so those those services are
simply removed from their IEPs with no
oversight or thought about why they
needed those services in the first place
there's nobody to go back to court and
say hey this is an inappropriate
placement because this child is losing
access to the Serv services that their
team has determined that they need so
for all of those reasons we think it's
just very bad practice to leave kids out
of home and without access to Advocates
and counsel um but those concerns first
of all don't stop when the pandemic ends
we think that this this is a practice
that has been adopted already during the
pandemic but we think needs to continue
beyond the pandemic because these kids
still have those same concerns the
issues that I just raised regarding
special education planning um and other
services and restraints of seclusion
those were problems before the pandemic
um but we also think that kids um kids
who are not in out of home placement
also need access to counsel all of these
kids when they are sentenced to um
probation or any any term of services
that is part of a larger case plan and
it's very important that they have
access to the services that they need um
through their delinquency case so that
they don't wind up in these out of home
placements and so if they're not
receiving the counseling and services
that the court has ordered or something
is going wrong in their um in their in
their service plan while even in their
homes they should have access to counsel
so that they don't wind up at the next
court hearings with their probation
officer saying that you know they're not
accessing counseling or they're doing
something wrong and therefore they need
to be placed out of home if they're not
receiving something or they're
struggling they should have access to a
council to council well beyond that all
already um Council reopens their case
before hearing so all this would do is
have the juvenile know that even though
they don't have a hearing coming up in
30 days they have a hearing coming up in
60 days they can pick up the phone and
call their counsel we do not think that
this will create an added burden on um
on the public defender system
because already they're sort of
scrambling to catch up 30 days before a
hearing so we think that this just makes
sense um in terms of of the second part
of 1A and section one which is I think
what the committee um has really
expressed concerns on about we think
that this provision is really
substantially different from what you
saw last year so as attorney skibby um
indicated last year HB 188 allowed for
um for representation by Council
ancillary proceedings anytime um those
proceedings had the same underlying
factual circumstances so it could mean
representation uh we didn't think that
it would mean this but you know I think
the committee pointed out it could mean
representation at a personal injury on a
personal injury claim it could mean
representation at a school proceeding
that's not how we intended it and um we
had a number of conversations with
stakeholders and really um tried to
understand what the concerns were and so
from from our perspective here um there
is a New Hampshire rule professional
conduct for attorneys and it's Rule
1.1a and that rule says um it requires
lawyers to conduct proper case repres
preparation it includes inquiry inter
into an analysis of factual and legal
elements of the case and use of methods
and procedures meeting the standards of
competent
practitioners notably the njdc report
that attorney scabby pointed out found
that New Hampshire attorneys
underutilize investigator to adequately
prepare cases so what we intended this
provision to mean um both last year and
now even more so this year is that if an
attorney decides that participation
whatever participation means it and it
doesn't have to mean full representation
but if an attorney decides that
participation in something other than
that child's delinquency court case is
necessary to prepare their case um and
represent them in the delinquency
proceeding then they should have the
freedom to do that and we simply think
that's what the rules of professional
conduct require so there's all kind a
school disciplinary hearing so if if a
if a child's underlying offense is based
on an assault that happened at school
and that child is also undergoing a
suspension or expulsion for that assault
there will be witnesses that
entails um
and the only the only real example that
I can think of is that if a violation of
conditional release is based
on an underlying action like a
suspension or
expulsion defeating that would
necessarily defeat the violation of
conditional release and that would be
necessary participation I can't think of
any other type of representation and I
don't think that means that it doesn't
exist but I can't think of any other
type of legal
representation that would be necessary
to effectively represent the child in
the delinquency case I can think of
advocacy that may be necessary I can
think of information gathering and
investigation that may be
necessary um but I think that by having
the reasonably necessary language in
there it limits
it adequately limits what an attorney
can do and certainly support this but
quote we support this bill in concept
and recommend further study uh regarding
the fiscal note I'm sure later today uh
excuse me later in this hearing you'll
hear from dcyf who um um agree uh that
this is a systemwide change that needs
to happen but needs to be divulged into
a very heavy investigative way um
regarding some crimes just to kind of
put this into perspective a waiver can
be asked from the defense attorney uh
it's kind of a fail safe but uh they may
or may or not the judge may or may not
approve that and still a child excuse me
young adult uh may be tried as an adult
so there are those checks and balances
that kind of create that that that again
like I said fail safe um the takeaway
from this is that this is needed um but
again we need to investigate this
further um as to the best way to move
forward to implement
this and I'm with that I'll be happy to
take any questions so are you suggesting
we turn this into some sort of a study
committee absolutely not that's a that's
a safe way to say that this bill is is
dead um I'm thinking something along
some form of professional commission um
that um professionals including law
enforcement officials um DCF members of
uh this body and the Senate um as well
um get together and have some form of
Brain Trust if you
will so are you suggesting we amend this
to make it a commission I am not
suggesting that at this time as I want
to get uh people together to see what we
can come forward with and and find the
best solution
forward okay thank you are there any
questions representative
yela so you're asking the committee to
itl this bill
nope for a
followup thank
you what is you your request of this
committee at this time it's
unclear okay are there any further
questions all right seeing none thank
you very
much up next is Richard headed from the
judicial branch requesting five
minutes thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee my name is
Richard HED I'm the judicial branches
government Affairs coordinator um and
I'm testifying on the assumption that
this bill would be going forward and not
relative to the policies but some of the
concerns the judicial branch has
regarding the implementation of this
type of a bill if it were to go forward
in its current form there are roughly um
uh
4700 um people who are currently in the
in the system that are aged 18 to 21
that would become juveniles under this
bill um about 655 of those are in
Superior Court a little over 4,000 of
those are in the Circuit Court um so the
implementation of this type of of a bill
would require us to treat those
individuals as juveniles so for example
part of the requirements of the Court
could be includes placement while
arraignment is being determined the
question is exactly where do you place a
20-year-old who would be subject to this
bill but would be considered a juvenile
you know it's unclear as to where
exactly we would be able to place those
individuals in terms of the process
juvenile cases are much more complex in
an earlier analysis that we had
performed um juvenile cases take about
14 times longer than other cases has a
significant impact on a court system
that's dealing with um
125,000 cases in the circuit court with
41 judges when you add that type of an
additional time uh requirement to cases
you're imposing a significant burden on
on the traditional Branch there also
just more more complex in terms of the
analysis that's required um so for
example during arraignments the court
has to evaluate the cognitive ability of
the individual the mental emotional
behavioral disorders special education
eligibility um and previous management
referrals that may have occurred with
this individual they're treated as
juveniles they're treated as a a
different um uh it's much different
analysis than for an adult in addition
there are requirements relative to
involving the parent or Guardians when
we're talking about an 181 19 20 21 year
old um we're not usually involving we we
usually don't have a situation where
there's a parent and typically Guardians
are no longer involved so it becomes
very unclear as to how the court manages
parents and Guardians in terms of the
current language of the
statute
um so just as an overall sort of concern
of the judicial branch this type of of a
change
would would create a significant burden
especially in the circuit courts
especially in um conquered Manchester
nashille and Keen where we have the
heaviest criminal loads um and and we
would see that there would be a need for
certainly additional Personnel in terms
of clerk management of these types of
cases and judicial resources um with
that I'll be happy to answer any
questions the committee may have thank
you thank you very
much so I I have a quick question so
where would we house said 14 year olds
would we house them with 20 year olds
it's at least unclear from the bill it
doesn't address that current currently
that's obviously a concern um and uh in
exactly how you you'd be placing folks
who are for all other purposes adults
into a juvenile situation is is unclear
to us in terms of of how that would
proceed and and could you please give me
the numbers again that you stated for
how many we currently have 18 to 20 year
olds sure um currently in the in terms
of criminal cases there are
4,688 cases of those a little over 4,000
of them are in Circuit
Court okay thank you very much are there
any further
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you for your time up next is
representative Jess Edwards to speak in
opposition to the bill he's asked for
three
minutes
can you turn
on on there oh there we go they're right
around here got it yeah um okay so thank
you madam chair I appreciate the
opportunity to come speak before your
committee um I I know that one of your
committee members two of your committee
members are U sponsors of this bill and
I I don't mean to denigrate their their
work at all uh I am uh opposed to this
bill and I'll I'll try to
explain why I I I haven't done the
detailed analysis that the previous
witness did so I'm I I my concerns are
more at sort of a strategic uh you know
uh concern level of of we don't know
what we don't know uh kind of thing and
uh I would just say that um I had posted
that this bill was going to be heard
today on our local community political
board and it created a lot of
um interest and I'm surprised folks from
Auburn aren't here today because they
seem pretty animated but I I think I'm
speaking on behalf of uh my constituents
Auburn Chester and Sandown that they
don't think this is a good idea um as we
talk about the maturity level and the
decision- making ability of young people
um I I I just want to establish the
Benchmark that this legislature has said
that 13year olds in law 13-year-olds are
mature enough and have the
decisionmaking authority enough for them
to begin undergoing gender reassignment
surgery which is a pretty tremendous
decision at the age of 13 they're also
able to elect to have an abortion
without parental notification so we've
already in law said that this age group
has a tremendous amount of ability to
make incredibly important uh life
changing
decisions uh we have recently as a house
passed HB
254 uh which if it becomes law would
essentially say that only those uh
juveniles who are have been convicted of
a a serious physical crime not property
crimes we would exempt property crimes
from being detained in uh the sununu
youth center and its replacement so I I
I'm just curious ious if we'd be adding
the 18 to 20y Old category to those that
would also now be green light to commit
property crime and and and if that's the
case uh I think as we look at TV and we
see the Looting taking the organized
looting that's taking place around the
country I I just I just don't want that
coming to New Hampshire I law might from
an unintended perspective tell um a
mature group of people who have access
to cars and mobility and everything that
they can just that uh New Hampshire is a
u open hunting season um I I I think if
we look at our experience with bail
reform in the last few years what we'll
see is that uh the the legislature had a
pretty good intent for bail reform and
um the judges have not implemented our
intent particularly well we've seen a
great deal more leniency in the bail
reform than what we had anticipated and
there are several initiatives to try to
tighten that back up and make it more
clear but U but I'm just concerned about
uh having our judges given more and more
discretion in this particular area when
I think they've not done a good job with
u managing bail reform as a re very
recent example um I would point out that
we've said that we're going to close
Center and replace it and none of the
sizing of that facility has been based
on adding some subset of 4,000 cases a
year so our whole sununu Center plan uh
would just go be going back to square
zero I guess um and then I'd also say
that we've spent a lot of money in the
last few years establishing a system of
care which basically provides
community-based resources to those uh in
need and and I think um uh and I think
this is I I don't know this for a fact
but as I understand it um in order for
the cunu center to close we need to
really rely on the cunu center to
provide system of care support to people
probably on a priority basis of some
kind uh and so all of a sudden we're I'm
I'm just wondering are we going to take
these 18 to 20 year olds and and now
give them priority for system of care
services because they've committed a
crime and their brother or sister did
not so
I um you can do it politely but this I
don't think this is good uh good policy
so I I'm happy to take questions I I'm
not as deep on this as other Witnesses
but I'm W I'm willing to
try so
um you're you're a veteran right I am
who so at what age um can kids can
people join the military uh I I think
under the current uh policies they can
uh sign up with their parental approval
at uh 17 uh they can do it completely on
their own at 18 uh and uh just to
elaborate on that uh I I when I served
in Afghanistan uh I I did meet young
people and uh they were there handling
extremely serious responsibilities on
behalf of their
nation and would you say that that is
not a decision that is made
lightly uh the decision to enter into
the military uh I I wouldn't say it's a
light decision no thank you yeah any
further questions seeing none thank you
so much all right thank you for your
time up next is um representative Mary
Beth walls speak in support of the bill
for one
minute thank you Madame chairman members
of the committee I'm represented of Mary
Beth walls I represent mayor Matt County
District 23 which is Bow and Dunbarton
um and I was for or am a former chair of
this committee and while on this
committee and as chair I actually had
the bill that raised the age of
delinquency from 16 to 18 which is why I
wandered in today I'm break from
education across the hall and wanted to
see what was happening here I'm under no
illusions that this bill is going to
pass as it is you know it was tough to
get it to 18 we faced a lot of
opposition and we left Major Crimes down
at 16 where um children between the ages
of 16 and 18 could be certified of as an
adult if they did commit something like
murder so we understood this is going on
I wanted to bring a couple things to the
attention of the committee one is is
that um Nebraska actually is the only
state in the Union I know of that has an
age of delinquency above 18 and they're
at 19 so it's possible to do it and
change happens incrementally and I would
encourage this committee to look at
doing it to 19 or 20 and no doubt we're
hearing testimony there are
complications for raising the age at all
um and I will bring some of them up for
your attention one is Pria the prison
rape elimination act which says you
cannot hold 18 19 20 year olds the same
facility as those under 18 okay no doubt
that would complicate things here in how
we hold um these people I also wanted to
just reference represent the prior
witness's testimony he talked about
4,000 cases in cunu that was 4,000 cases
in the courts not 4,000 people
incarcerated and I just didn't want to
complate that data you know I'm sure the
vast majority of those 4,000 cases that
they were testifying about in the court
are misdemeanors without any sort of
jail time or any sort of incarceration
associated with them so understand that
the burden on the court of 4,000 cases
is totally separate from whatever burden
will arise due to incarceration of
somebody on one of these um so I just
wanted to to make sure that that was
clear to the committee as well so I
would encourage you to turn this into a
study committee or commission or
something along the way to look at this
at the time I worked to raise the age of
delinquency to 18 I would love to have
taken it even to want I was no fool I
knew that wasn't going to happen just
getting it at 18 was a very heavy lift
but I think it's a valid concern that
warrants examination there's no doubt
there's a vast difference in maturity of
18 19 20 21 year olds some are very
mature they're going to go over to
Afghanistan and do very major things
there are others that are just
constantly making bad decisions and
their lack of brain development shows
every day and I think it's possible to
thread the needle to come up with
something that recognizes that it's not
a one-size fits-all that there is a
difference in maturity and that there
are some juveniles there are some young
adults that need our support in ways
that others don't thank you very much
okay thank you are there any questions
seeing none thank you so much thank you
and the last speaker is um director Joe
ripsom of dcyf to speak for three
minutes
good morning members of the committee
Joe ripson director DCF great to see
everybody today um I only signed in to
provide information um we do have
obviously many many implementation
concerns with something like this moving
forward as written right if you're
talking about a potential of 4,700
additional individuals entering the
juvenile justice system without you know
preparation Ado so that would be really
really difficult what I did want to say
though is that that you know we do know
a lot about brain signs with adolescence
at this point that wasn't known years
ago we know that while the intellectual
maturity for most young people is age 16
their social emotional maturity maturity
and their executive function doesn't
fully develop until they're in their mid
20s certainly not suggesting that the
law should change to to make it in the
mid 20s just to say that I think this is
a reasonable um issue for folks to take
seriously around how do we make sure
that we're addressing people's needs in
a meaningful and thoughtful way um that
understands kind of their their maturity
level their decision- making their
intellectual capacity and doesn't
necessarily have a one- siiz fits-all um
I do not think that the way that this is
drafted which would just change the age
to 21 does that but I do think it's
something that's worth the examination
of folks and I do appreciate
representative for bringing forward this
idea that this is something that New
Hampshire should start thinking about
and figuring out of approach to make
sure that we treat young adults in a way
that matches with their intellectual um
maturity and developmental realities and
with that I'll take questions are there
any
questions seeing none thank you so much
okay so I'm gonna close the public
hearing on HB
1568 and we have about nine minutes
until our next
it's
I
e
spe
I don't
think
where
than good
to thank you thank you by
everybody
thank
you good morning I'm representative
Cornell Manchester yeah pull it a little
closer representing district 18 and I'm
also on the education committee I'm
introducing Bill 1531 today which would
modifies the duty scope and membership
of the oversight Commission on um
Children's Services it's in the office
of the child advocate um it's RSA
21-v
and what this does is overlooks the
programs um the
agencies the practices to make sure that
um our children are being cared for the
agencies are doing what they're supposed
to be doing so this bill is to modify
that commission update it the office of
child advocate I believe is going
through some changes on fortunately the
child advocate is leaving and so um that
will be under New Direction they'll be
doing new things so this is to try and
keep up with that um this bill is a work
in progress I I believe you're going to
hear of different ideas and this is just
to really get the ball
going okay are there any questions for
representative Cornell representative
yella yes thank you and thank you for
taking the question um pleasure so this
is repealing the entire statute and and
reenacting it what what are the the uh I
guess deficiencies that you're seeing or
that that you see that that warrants uh
a re a whole redesign of the statute and
I I think some of the things that it's
overseen aren't in place anymore or
their scope and Mission have changed um
I think the membership of the commission
um could do some changes for different
people different agencies to do that so
it's it's just an update and
review any further
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much well thank
you and up next is um Senator Whitley to
speak in support of the bill for five
minutes thank you Madame chair good
afternoon good morning members of the
committee my name is Becky Whitley I
represent Senate district 15 including
conquered hener hopkington and Warner
and I'm really pleased to be in front of
this committee I care deeply about
children and families and um want to
speak in support of Representative
Cornell's bill um just wanted to clarify
representative yella that the bill
doesn't repeal the entire statute it
really just focuses on the oversight
commission um and uh retains a lot of
their work but sort of rethinks its role
and so I wanted to point out to that um
um representative Cornell and I and
others fully recognize that the office
of child advocate is actually going
through a very um in-depth strategic
planning process and part of that work
and um I'm sure the child advocate can
speak to this part of their work is
really looking at the role of the
commission um as the office has evolved
and I um uh we are uh working to convene
a work group with the office of child
advocate with um rep uh with
representative rice with representative
Cornell and Sharon Carson who's the
chair of the oversight commission and
then other Advocates to make sure we're
aligning uh the work that the strategic
planning process is undertaking and also
trying to
streamline um some of our work as a
legislature to look at Children's
Services there are lots of committees
well- meaning trying to look at system
issues and I think when we're talking
about children it's really important
that we are are um looking about our uh
our system as a whole and making sure
it's efficient making sure kids are
getting timely care families are
supported when they need to um so this
is an effort to to streamline those
efforts um I agree that it is a work in
progress this is just something to get
on paper to work from and there there is
a strong working group that's going to
be continuing to look at this work and
align it with the um oca's strategic
planning process so I'm happy to answer
any questions um and defer any regarding
the strategic planning process to Mora
thank you are there any
questions
representative yella yes thank you
um thank you for the clarification about
about what this bill is trying to do
um
do what do you think that um maybe the
current thing that this um commission is
is doing NE that that needs to be
updated is it um need a broader scope is
it is it too broad and we need to focus
its efforts um or are we not sure and
we're still waiting for um um this this
plan to be formed thank you yeah thank
you for the question I think when the
statute so the statute was passed and
then it was then it evolved as the child
advocate built out her office um and now
I think um many years into the office
it's been what four years since the
office was established I think it's a
perfect time to look at the role of the
commission and so I wouldn't say it's
you know it's changing it a lot or
improving it I think it's just
reimagining how we can um play a part in
that oversight mechanism and work
alongside the office of child advocate
so I think there's also some thought
about um there are existing commissions
that work really well and there um I
don't know if folks are familiar with
the governor's uh uh drug uh I don't
know what it's called but the um
Commission on drug oversight and they
have many tasks for and so the way that
this was designed was to sort of mimic
that that that commission to sort of
think through you know different task
force to achieve uh the system work and
that's that's the other piece to it
since the commission was set up and the
office of child advocate has been set up
there has been a lot of system reform so
through 135f through this children's
system of care the state looks very
different we are already delivering
services to children in a different way
and so we need to evolve in our
oversight to to match that system reform
and have a a continued focus on system
level
work follow up yes yes thank you and
thank you uh for your answer um it one
of the tasks that are is listed on page
two line 30 is to develop a mission and
goals and objectives yeah so it seems
like
um we don't know what we want them to do
that's for the task forces so we're
going to have the commission and then
perhaps the commission will want to say
well we need a task force on children's
Behavioral Health and then that task
force will sort of develop the work from
there okay thank you thank you for the
question any other
questions okay thank you so much thank
you and up next is um Moira O'Neal from
the office of the Advocate to speak in
opposition to the bill and she does have
written
testimony good morning Madam chair
members of the committee thank you for
the opportunity to speak today for the
record my name is Moira O'Neal I'm the
child advocate for the State of New
Hampshire um and and just uh with
regrets that there's only an opportunity
to say that you
can you pull the mic a little closer we
have the machines back here that are
running so it's it's hard to hear if
you're not like right up in the mic is
this better yes thank you can you hear
me now
sorry so um I regret that the the
classifications of support for the bill
are either support or or or oppose and
we we support the concept of this bill
um but we oppose it as written um and
I'll um uh just re review with you a
little bit I I understand that there's
going to be some work done to make some
changes my testimony includes uh many of
the areas that we think need to be
adjusted so I can go through that
testimony now and give you that
information or wait until the the group
has made more would you like to hear
more of it now just thinking about the
time for the committee that has
available that's that do you have any
questions oh I mean we 20 minutes so
okay sure all right so let as long as
you can do it in 20 minutes I I believe
I can I believe I can for once I'm not
too too lengthy here so the house bill
as you've heard it modifies membership
duties scope of the oversight commission
um it also provides an appropriation um
for the commission's duties and it was
um and and and it's addressing where the
commission is at today originally the
commission was established along with
the office of the child advocate in
response to child tragedies that
signaled some need for reforms in New
Hampshire child protective system so and
as you just heard from Senator Whitley
the system is now a very different
system um thanks much to that um so so
that's why we cons we we support this
bill in terms of that it's a time for a
little bit of change but we do think
there's some clarification so the
expectation of the office of the child
advocate is to ensure
transparency examination of State
systems performance and Assurance of a
system that operates in the best
interest of children
the role of the current iteration of the
commission is in addition to vetting
candidates for the child Advocates
position is to provide oversight of the
office and to collaborate in promoting
system improvements and best practices
so I think what may have happened in the
past four years was that there was a
great emphasis on vetting candidates for
this position and then the off and then
the commission didn't really find its
feet and and begin to operate under the
statute or perhaps the statute wasn't
clear enough for them to find what their
role was so this is really timely um
Senator Whitley mentioned that the
office of the child advocate is in the
process right now of finishing up a
strategic plan for the next three years
um and in that process we collected
information from all around the
community including oversight commission
members because of that really important
relationship that's intended to be there
um eight members of the commission
participated in stakeholder interviews
um and we learned that um there were
several suggestions and recommendations
on how to strengthen that commission um
and those themes included increasing
role Clarity for the commission
considering a broader role for the
commission expanding the composition of
the commission to include Youth and
others there is a position for a youth
on the commission now that has yet to be
filled um and that's new we changed that
two years ago um but also they want to
more closely connect the commission to
the actual work with children through
site visits um to programs or doing
shared case reviews so getting to know
more of what's happening in the field
and then finally establishing a more
frequent and substantive Cadence of
meetings and communication because in
the last I would say almost two years
the the commission really sort of ceased
to function in many ways it wasn't
meeting and that was that was the
feedback we got from Commission members
so as you see the input from the
commission members who participated in
the interviews reflected you know this
the what's the changes that are
materializing in this bill so it just
happens um we we hadn't coordinated that
feedback but that was um that's how it
it sort of developed so today I
respectfully suggest that several
aspects of the bill do require um
clarification and it's a little
confusing the the bill is a little
bit disc ulating maybe I could say um so
I'm going to I'm going to talk about
changes in four categories one is
clarifying the administrative head of
the office of the child advocate two is
the apparent dual roles and purpose of
the proposed commission um membership of
the commission and then the fourth is
administration of the commission
including budget management so
clarification of the administrative head
it's a small thing but just logistically
it could be Troublesome there is no
director of the office of the child
advocate under RSA 21 V1 section two the
child advocate is the administrative
head of the office a minor detail but
something that could be um could be
confusing at some
point so the proposed commission appears
to have dual roles and purpose so it it
appears that the roles and purpose for
the commission may actually even be in
Conflict so specifically in one role it
appears the commiss would act somewhat
as Children's Services collaborative or
a cabinet with a role of examining
service needs for children as well as
available resources to meet those needs
but in the other role the commission
acts as oversight of the office of the
child advocate so beginning um on page
two line 23 and forward the bill
establishes capacity within the
commission to uh convene task forces as
Senator Whitley was just talking about
to report on available programs funding
onet Mees um and later further on um as
well as identify program areas where
improved coordination is needed then
later on page three line four it
establishes duties of the commission
that include making recommendations
regarding creating a unified Statewide
administrative uh programs and services
for children I think this is coming from
the discussion in the last session about
creating a separate Agency for
children's services um which we did
support
so that all appears to be looking having
a role where you're looking at the
system and you're making recommendations
then alternatively also on page three in
line four forward it articulates that
the commission's role of oversight of
the office of the child advocate so in
this section the examination of delivery
of services is described as the offices
responsibility which the commission
oversees and here the potential for
conflict exists because it propos
proposes that the child advocate be both
a member and the executive director of
the commission th positioning the office
to oversee
itself and then and I and I'm sure
that's not intended I think it's just an
oversight of combining some ideas
there's a further potential conflict in
that membership that I'll talk about in
a minute includes state agencies that
under RSA 21 V1 over which the office
has oversight so that would be providing
oversight of the office so the overseen
is overseen and the overse overseas
itself and so that just doesn't work and
we just have to work that out a lot of
overseers going on you wouldn't want
that
codified and I appreciate that people
put these things together fast and and
language is is complicated but we want
to make sure it's pointed out um so the
commission's further proposed to have a
partnership with the office in reviewing
services collaborating to identify best
practices so that language is in line
with the proposed role of service
collaborative however it's not inclusive
of all the members of the task force so
there's so in some senses you're going
in the right direction and then others
it's overlapping so the question is
raised about the intent of the bill and
I think that's what needs to be
clarified do we want to establish an
advisory collaborative for the purpose
of supporting and collaborating with the
office of the child advocate examining
Services making recommendations impr
proving or does the bill establish
oversight and support of the office and
the child advocate once that purpose is
clarified I think the bill will be
clear do you have a question
representative I'm happy to be
interrupted do you want to go ahead go
ahead yeah that's yeah go ahead thank
you thank you um yes I was definitely
confused I'm confused um because it
seems like they're doing the work and
then also trying to oversee the work and
so um it seems to me that some of the
things that they want to do
um are outside the scope of the current
child advocate and um and so that they
wanted the opportunity to do that work
and they wanted the child advocate to be
a part of that process but then they're
also um it seems like this this
commission is really was formed based on
the current RSA is for oversight and um
and to collaborate with the office I
guess with um
implementing the suggestions and methods
that they could do that um you know
whether that become legisl U come Lobby
us or what whatever the case may be but
this seems to be changing the the role
for more of oversight to doing the work
is
that is this really two different
commissions and should this is this its
own commission that's trying to do the
work
for um services like understanding the
services and then there's a separate
commission that is oversight oversight
over the office is that okay so thank
you for thank you for that question I as
I said it's it's a little
discombobulating um you have several
questions in there yeah number one it
doesn't it doesn't address further
jurisdiction than the office already has
um in September of
2020 the office's jurisdiction expanded
considerably so RSA 21 um mandates that
the child advocate oversee all CH All
Children's Services any service that a
child is provided that may be um either
provided for paid for or arranged for by
the state of New Hampshire so the so the
jurisdiction is quite broad um and it's
possible that one rationale for a
commission on children's services um is
created to both um help guide advise and
give some heft to this really broad
jurisdiction because uh right now in
July of 2022 the office will be up to
seven and a half positions um and that's
really not necessarily possible to to do
all of the systemic things that the
office would need to do so it does help
and there currently is no advisory body
for the office of the child advocate so
in that sense it's not a bad idea the
question is is it is there also a need
for oversight of the office um and that
that's a good question to look elsewhere
around the country to see do these
offices have oversight um in Connecticut
where I'm most familiar they did have an
advisory council at one point but they
abolished it and so most of these
offices don't actually have oversight
because they are so responsible to the
public I suppose and also because they
do not have enforcement power so they
don't so so they're not really in a
position to make decisions for the state
that that that people would be concerned
about in terms of responsibility um and
certainly All State a agencies um are
are responsible to follow the law and
and perform their duties the way they
need to do Under the Attorney General's
jurisdiction so so those are questions
that really need to be teased out little
a little bit more as we clarify what's
the purpose of this bill and how and
what would be the most effective and
useful um commission or body that's
working with or over the office of the
child
advocate so the answer is uh TBD to be
to be
decided do you have a
followup so many questions
just that's I think I think if we talk
after I give you some
clarification okay okay so the next
section that I wanted to address was
membership that's proposed in the bill
um there's some changes that are
proposed um the office identified a few
important stakeholders are not included
um there are some categories of members
that may actually overlap if there's
providers or advocacy and then there's
other options they may be the same
people so you could cut down the number
of those people in order to replace them
with the people we think are important
to include um and so I've provided a
table that shows those that are proposed
in the bill and then the and then what
we propose um in an amendment would be
to have two fewer child advocacy
organizations there'd be two of those
one more individual with lived
experience as a child and and one of the
reasons for that is not only because
their input is so important but we're
finding with young people it's very
difficult to make themselves available
for these kinds of proceedings um and so
if you have two you can increase the
odds that at least one will participate
um the maintain the foster parent um we
suggest including an individual who has
experience as a parent involved with the
system um this is a really important
perspective because it gives us their
experience and how better to work with
them um leave it the one professional
provider for legislators from the
executive branch and the judicial branch
the Attorney General we wouldn't change
the Comm commissioner the DCF director
the Bureau of children's Behavioral
Health director the Medicaid services
director Department of Education
commissioner the office of the child
advocate we would remove for the
conflicting uh points that we made the
Bureau of Developmental Services
director we would add because
developmental disabilities is one of the
biggest issues that we see being
unaddressed right now in New Hampshire
um the Circuit Court administrative
judges we've added one
to that to include someone else with
expertise um in the court systems um
Council on thriving children we left
system of care advisory committee this
is where we thought there would probably
be overlap because everyone is a member
of the system advisory committee I think
they have about a hundred members and
most of the people listed already belong
to that um a public defender and we
added back a chief of police there have
been two chiefs of police on the
committee on the commission to to date
they haven't been entirely engage we
haven't gotten to a point where we've
been able to engage them in the work of
the commission as intended and we're
constantly seeing that there is a role
for police that's implicated in a lot of
the system issues that we're finding so
it's important to keep them on the board
now having listed all those people the
other conflict that I mentioned having
Department of Health and Human Services
um representation on here um would again
create them overseeing the agency that
over oversees them if that is the
purpose of the off of the commission to
oversee the office of the child advocate
and I explain that a little bit further
through here and then um the last point
is administration of the commission
including budget management so there's
an allocation of
$150,000 um it and it also includes that
the administration of this committee um
would um would be fall under the child
advocate being the executive director so
if the oversight role of the commission
is altered and the purpose of the
commission is intended as a type of
collaborative of children's services and
the executive decero would be acceptable
in that case though the concern would be
the expected workload of the child
advocate in the office um the duties of
the executive director are not described
other than to say that they coordinate
administrative support that's um from
all executive branch departments um the
Department administrative support is not
clear in here what that looks like the
office already carries a pretty heavy
burden in terms of workload for which
it's under resource so it would be
important to understand the expectations
of the executive director to ensure that
the office services are not impeded by
additional administrative obligations
for example who would be responsible to
produce the annual report that's listed
on page four line three and overseeing
the commission Budget on page four line
nine um and it's not whe clear whether
the allocations of $150,000 would be
available to support these
administrative responsibilities for the
office or special projects um so sorry
that we've got so many questions here um
we do welcome this conversation it
definitely is timely um and we'd love to
have um some kind of a body that um is
is useful and effective and and helpful
in furthering the Improvement of
services for children and the outcomes
that children receive so I'll stop there
if you have more questions I'm happy to
take them are there any further
questions representative
long thank you madam
chair
um with respect to the with respect to
the uh strategic plan do you think that
strategic plan could help in developing
this there'll be some recommendations
with which
um you know getting your your opinion
has to where this uh where this office
ought to be going after these last four
years sure thank you for that question
so the Strategic plan is designed to
guide the office of the child advocate
going further um we we interviewed
members of the oversight Commission on
children's services because of their
unique statutory relationship to the
office we thought it was important to
get their input for their vision for the
office of the child advocate it was
completely
serendipitously that we got a lot of
feedback from the members of the
commission um that addressed changes
that needed to happen in the commission
itself and so we are sort of we're sort
of looking at this at how can we
create a collaborative or you know a
situation where everyone is working um
as best they can to to promote and
further children
uh children's experiences and outcomes
in the services that they receive so I
think at this point in the draft we've
only made sort of superficial
recommendations about the oversight
Commission in terms of its
relationship and the way that it um it
meets and
engages um we also have part of our data
collection was around um priority issues
that need to be addressed and so looking
at those priority issues those could be
adopted by the over site commission I
think I I tread carefully here because I
because I don't think in the current
iteration of the statute and in this
proposed one the office of the child
advocate is not in a position to direct
the oversight commission and what they
need to do um and so we can only say hey
we found this information that you may
want to use to think about um and in
fact we did approach the um the chair to
say it was important at least to convene
a meeting because people eager to get
back to work um on the commission but
other than that it's you know it's not
really our place um to to address that
if this bill were articulated in a way
that you ultimately there was a
collaborative supportive relationship
then I could see the the what if that
was a a collaborative Children's
Services Commission um they may look to
the child advocate strategic plan
um as something that they could further
um that would give them a really good
framework we're hoping that in general
this is going to give um some direction
for all of us because it was such a
CommunityWide assessment um that isn't
just within the office that we're
looking at issues for kids it would be
for everyone so it it will certainly be
a useful document but we can't direct
the commission unless we're the
executive
director follow up I may chair uh yeah I
I understand the directing uh but I'm
just thinking maybe an exit interview uh
is what we're looking at uh with respect
to youth I I I like that idea having
Youth
represented um would you have that under
the
public I guess it would have to be
uh or under government groups that
may have a PP a member a youth member I
I was just looking where you would think
the youth would fit into your
recommendation of representation yeah
thank you for that question they are
they are in the Bill they are listed
under the public and I I would recommend
keeping them there they are members of
the public you could think of them as
consumers of um of children's services
um and so I do think that they fit well
and and if the focus is in all state
services on consumer satisfaction um
then that's that's a good sort of place
and um and representation of the um of
the of their of their
perspective okay great thank you are
there any further
questions seeing none all right thank
you very much and I'm closing the
hearing on House Bill 1531 and we will
be back at 1 o
clock
e
right right right
yeah might not go
yeah Pages AR yeah yeah so you know
I
yesterday I just
wanted so when we had that discussion
last night I was just a little bit you
knew that right oh okay
okay yeah
yeah oh yes right
yeah yeah you know I actually have I
everything in the order I like to have
everything in the order because
I like to be
organized and then I have this and then
I write notes and then I tear it out and
I put it on top of
this
yeah
hi nice to meet you thank you so
much Darry I'm from Derry yes oh okay
great I love it I love it I'm
honored
I hope we enjoyed
lunch for um anyone who has never been
here before if you intend to testify you
need to fill out a pink card that are
over on the
table
and um I'm going to open the public
hearing on House Bill 1416 and I'll
recognize representative Amanda
Balden yeah we just need you to keep it
up close with the machines it's really
hard to hear back
here yep just turn and turn it on when
you have the red around here there you
go thank you okay um my name is Amanda
Balden represent hillsb District 12
thanks for um hearing this bill today
I'll keep it really brief um currently
the standard New Hampshire parenting
plan requires both unmarried parents to
give their consent before a child can
receive non-emergency Health Care um
Mental Health Care such as talk therapy
falls under that umbrella um the New
Hampshire Suicide Prevention Council
recently published its 2020 Suicide
Prevention plan which includes a go to
increase access to treatment for mental
illness I believe this legislation is in
alignment with that
goal um when two parents are married one
is obviously permitted to enroll their
child in mental health care without the
consent of the other parent um so I
don't see why unmarried parents should
be limited in a way that married parents
are not um children don't always have
solid and open relationships with their
parents I think any parent here has
certainly experienced that um and this
is going to be aggravated by divorce uh
most definitely if a child in a divorced
or unmarried parent situation is willing
to go to one parent with their mental
health issues and their concerns but not
to another parent um it can be difficult
to get total buyin without having to
cause additional stress to the child and
furthermore in situations of possible
child abuse by one parent it's important
for the child to be able to access
mental health support without having to
obtain the consent of the possible
abuser um this bill I don't intend for
it to give cart blanch to either parent
just to allow treatment to begin um
instead of preventing access to
treatment entirely allow the child to
enter mental health treatment as soon as
possible and then leave it to the adults
to settle the issue in court if there is
substantial disagreement um so basically
just open the door let's get started um
most of the mental health care available
in New Hampshire is uh uh legitimate and
reasonably provided there aren't a lot
of situations where it's possible for
someone to take their child to a mental
health provider who's going to be
harming the child um so to be able to
move forward and get mental health
treatment started and then to leave it
to the adults to figure out the details
or debate it later in the court system I
think is ideal it's in the best interest
of the child to be able to proceed with
that kind of treatment um instead of
having to delay the onset of treatment
until the until after the adults have
settled their
differences and that's all I have thank
you representative
yella thank you and uh thank you for
taking the question um it seems like
your bill is trying to address that they
both have to have Buy in from for um
before the services are provided um what
if if instead of both of them have to
have Buy in what if they just have to
the one parent has to just notify the
other person like if they're on their
way to the thing on the way to the
service and they just say hey I'm on my
way um I'm doing it kind of a thing they
don't have to have Buy in but the other
person would know before the treatment
actually starts so that you know let's
say it was um harmful or they had a
disagreement then they would be able to
express that and um take appropriate a
action maybe even with the authorities
if necessary um what would you what
would you say to that thanks for the
question um as far as involving the
authorities um I think it depends on the
situation and whether or not it's
appropriate to bring police around a
child who's maybe you know the range of
situations in which it you realize as a
parent that Mental Health Care is needed
they're wide ranging and you may or may
not need the involvement of uh law
enforcement but you may still still
desperately need mental health care
especially because it's the sort of
issue that can compound pretty quickly
into an emergency situation um depending
on what's going on with the child the
you know obviously we're talking about a
huge topic of just mental health in
general um super vague there um the bill
uh requires that the parent who
consented a loone to the mental health
care notify the other parent within 30
days of the onset of treatment and I
think that that's reasonable and needs
to be reasonable um I don't think that
it's reasonable to expect someone to be
making a phone call when they're in the
middle of a crisis potentially um and I
think that 30 days is just uh on par for
normal uh like New Hampshire uh statute
I think that's probably the most that we
can expect from someone is that they
have an opportunity for things to calm
down and to be able to communicate
through an attorney or directly to the
other person um and then everyone can
see how the treatment's proceeding maybe
before taking it to court so my concern
would be um what what
if the parent that is is seeking the
mental health treatment for the child is
not the parent that's going to be paying
for this and they in Turn end up getting
a bill before that 30 days and haven't
been notified I could see that causing
quite an adversarial
situation and probably what's I'm
guessing could probably already be
adversarial you know we don't want to we
don't want to put
more fighting in there you
know I I agree that um we don't want to
be setting people up who are already in
Conflict to have more conflict um but if
they're already in Conflict to the
extent that one person is willing to
interfere and potentially um prevent the
child from accessing mental health care
I think that we need to go back to
focusing on the benefits for the child
and if there's some kind of you know a
few hundred dollars here and there sort
of even upwards of a thousand dollar
bill that needs to be managed after the
fact that's I think that's the idea is
that we allow the child to get health
care in a way that I I feel like the
complexity of mental healthare is that
um an emergency situation is when
something has gone untreated for a very
very long time and it seems unnecessary
to let things go for that long if
there's a disagreement between parents
that may just simply be Financial or
maybe ideological or something like that
right what I but what I'm what I'm
saying is is that um if if that is how
the parent finds out that their child
has gotten help right it's it's not
necessarily the money it's the fact that
the other parent has not notified them
until 30 days later and they're finding
out that their child's in
crisis through a bill in the mail if you
wanted to make it shorter I mean I don't
think that a phone call is like in the
middle of the ordeal day after because
or like seven days or something you know
I just don't want to see them getting a
bill and saying oh so my child's in
crisis wait what the billing can take a
long time anyway I mean you know how it
is dealing with medical bills oh yeah um
that you think something else is all set
and the insurance paid for it and then
two months later they you know the
hospital mails you something and you're
like what what do they need $20 for um
and uh I think think that the instances
in which someone um has the entirety of
the financial obligation for medical
expenses and only shares half of the
decision- making um responsibility are
probably rare and I would think that the
court would be encouraging people to
share in the expenses whenever possible
if they're sharing in the decision-
making okay um but I'd be willing to
shorten the length of time um but I
don't see a benefit to denying the child
mental health care because parents can't
get along right and I'm not saying to
deny them I'm more concerned about the
time frame and a parent being notified
of a mental health crisis via a medical
bill yeah and that's what I mean is that
I think it currently there are children
being denied mental health care because
parents can't get along the court system
is very backed up and enabling one
parent to just go ahead and healthare um
I think would help countless
children especially children that are in
a divorce situation
representative yella yes thank you and
thank you for taking the followup
um would you believe that um there
is even even when um there is sha shared
payment responsibilities for the medical
services that the actual responsibility
from the um provider is
only to a single parent and then the
other parent has to request the funds
from the from the other parent and so um
when you say that there is the
possibility that you know they they just
have to go and request it if the person
isn't notified ahead of time that could
also encourage them to not pay their
half and then would be essentially
another opportunity child be able to
access mental health care than it is
that we prevent people who are probably
already very Petty and engaged in
extensive um litigation to just add one
more filing to the
docket like I think that those are
extraneous situations and I think that
we need to think about the
kids okay are there any further
questions right seeing down thank you
very much thank you should I turn this
off or leave it on uh turn it off and
then we'll have the next speaker turn it
on and up next next is representative
David love um he didn't say whether he
supports it or not but requested two
minutes thank you madam chair thank you
committee members uh for the record my
name is representative David love I
represent Rockingham 6 which is Derry
and uh just uh I I Comm in the you know
uh representative for taking interest in
this it's uh well-meaning but uh as uh
representative rice and Y Keller both
pointed out there some holes in it and
I'd like to point out another one
serious Hole uh it's been my personal
experience um you know when I got
divorced I had uh you know 50% shared
parenting and uh you know my my ex-wife
showed up uh with my daughter and said
oh yeah she's on psych
meds I never had any any idea that she
was even going to see a psychiatrist or
this is 11 years old a few hours later I
get an 11y old that wants to kill
herself you know God's honest truth and
uh you know I had no I had no idea what
she was on I know and then go look up
what it was
and lot of these psych drugs have have
Suicidal Thoughts as as one of the side
side effects and for one parent to have
no idea that this is going on is uh you
know it's a travesty of Justice really
um you know I uh you know the the the
courts uh sometimes sometimes they they
they go sideways you know uh of
representative rice and I have talked
about uh you know uh that uh Family
Court judges are human beings and when
they get they get overloaded and they
get some real tough cases uh one or the
other you know in the next five cases
gets discriminated against really uh you
know some of the some of these tough
cases are are horrendous but we don't uh
judicial discretion is is
a as an out for them I I think that
needs to be reeled in you know and we
can we have a chance to do that with
this bill for for sure um you know uh
medical decisions unless it's an
emergency situation should be shared by
both parents you know and uh you know un
unless one's a you know a bad alcoholic
or you know out of their mind whatever
you know um you know unless unless is a
good reason not to um you know and uh
the judges have to have to step up and
and put this in writing and you know I
don't want to see anybody else go
through what I went through you know it
was you know a good 10 hours was a hell
you know before they they got her
stabilized and U you know to have have
have to sit there and and have you know
10 minutes uh before my ex-wife leaves
the house is when I get the uh the
notification that she's on this medicine
um wasn't right and uh you know it
sounds like this this well-meaning bill
needs a few amendments or or you know
needs to go to a study committee or
whatever for me uh to you know to fix it
that's it okay are there any questions
for representative
love okay seeing n thank you so
much okay I don't have any more pink
cards was there anyone else to testify
on this
bill okay I'm closing the hearing on
House Bill
1416 and we'll have 10 minutes until our
next scheduled bill at
1:30
on
just
for
you
e
C
repr
for
spe
read
for
to
e
and we are back so I'm going to open the
public hearing on HB 139
six and um representative Amanda Balden
will be speaking in favor of her
bill hello
again um I recognize that I have three
bills in your committee back toback so
I've made an I did that on
purpose uh thank you that saves my time
and I want to save your time by making
all of my testimony as short as possible
um so again I'm Amanda Balden represent
hillsbor District
12 um on 1396 I just think that a
uniform support order should have a due
date without a due date the meaning of
Rees is unclear to all parties involved
um there's no space on the current
uniform support order um for the judge
to specify due date in standing order 5A
on page six which I provided to you all
but I'm sure you million times that was
great um it attempts to speak to due
dates but it's really vague
so um let's see if I can find it really
quickly it says if no date appears in
paragraph five of the uniform support
order the first support payment shall be
due on the date this order is signed by
the judge so in a way it kind of and I
think that this leaves a lot open to
litigation because there's some words
that can be parsed certainly
um and obviously like the the the
standing order 5A in combination with um
what is it paragraph five um are being
used to establish a due date but I think
that it's um insufficiently clear and uh
I also provided you with RSA 461a colon
14 part uh what is that eight 18 um
which might be like the last page that I
gave you uh it talks about when a reage
equals or exceeds the equivalent of
eight weeks of Child Support under the
existing order how do you
determine when something's late if the
due date is so unclear is it due within
the month is it due by the date that is
not named as a due date um I think those
are some pretty
big questions and additionally if
someone's on a private um child support
payment setup and they're um the other
parents been reliably paying and then
something happens and they want to
pursue they have a right to pursue
um what do you call it uh the Bureau of
Child Support Services can um attach the
wages thank you yeah um I included the
forms um because again it's really
unclear at what point someone would
sufficiently be late in order to qualify
in order for the obl obligate to qualify
for garnishment through the Bureau of
char a due date would clarify things
make
all this straightforward and simple in a
lot of ways and make the conversation of
like they're late they're not late more
straightforward and a lot shorter and
hopefully reduce litigation so that's
all thanks okay are there any questions
for representative
Balden representative
yella thank you and thank you for uh
taking the question
um would it surprise you that the that
the court would not garnish wages or um
really seek much enforcement
uh for non-payment until there was a
substantial amount let's say
$10,000 um in back child support or or
payment and um so if there was something
that was like $500 that it's going to be
late that that the court
might not actually enforce that due date
and
so
I'm would you believe that to be correct
and would you expect that that maybe we
should change also the enforcement of
that to be a lower amount um so that
these due dates are actually like
meaningful in some way thank you thanks
for the question I mean I think that
that is the problem is that the way that
due dates are sort of worded and
referred to too currently or too vague
to be enforced um but also specifically
I was trying to refer to when someone um
is the oblige and the obligor um fails
to pay on time um I couldn't find um
where I had read in the past that uh I
couldn't find the the actual wording but
it's my understanding that so I didn't
print it for you but my understanding
that once someone is 30 days behind um
the oblige has the right to request that
the Bureau of Child Support Services um
begin managing the processing of the
payments instead of payment and that's
really what I'm referring to when I say
that that uh it's difficult for someone
to determine when they should be
contacting the Bureau of Child Support
Services if the due date is not even
clear to the oblige um how do you know
when that 30 days is passed and you have
a right to fill out the form you have a
right to start that conversation um and
then with this I think in both cases
with the 8 weeks and the 30
days it seems like all that anyone's
left to do in any of those situations
just wait an extraordinarily long time
um until they can be absolutely
confident and that doesn't seem to be in
the best interest of
anyone participating I don't think that
that was the intent in having
institutions like the Bureau of Child
Support Services and having these these
statutes I don't think that the the
intent was for someone to have to wait
an extraordinarily long time beyond what
was specified in law so that they can be
sure that they're satisfying the law and
so I think that just a simple due date
on the uniform support order would
provide the are you outet
represent and would
you
um agree that with the amount of cases
that are handled prosay that reading
this paperwork it would really make it
more clear for people to have a better
understanding of what exactly is
expected of them and
when you get me yeah that's 100% it it
someone shouldn't have to turn to the
seventh page of the legal ease and fine
print literally smaller print in the
back of the uniform support order to
figure out whether or not um they should
be pursuing the obl obligor um or not
you know and whether they they have to
wait and you know it's certainly
complicated and if you're going to be
concerned about um receiving child
support payments just 30 days out from
when they were due then I imagine that
you don't have the financial means to
hire an attorney at that point and it
being um plain English is important so
thanks for understanding I'm glad it
feel understood you know that was the
intent with the bill so let's make it
simple okay are there any further
questions right seeing none thank you
very much see you soon okay I don't have
any other pink cards for this bill so I
will be closing the hearing on hb3 for
this
bill yeah okay you need to bring them
forward ignore that I just gaveled
nobody heard
that are there is there anyone else that
has a pink card for this
bill no okay
so um up next is Vivian Gerard
to speak in support of the bill for
three minutes and she has um she does
have written
testimony this is
yours if you want to just like hand it
there and we'll pass them around that'd
be
great
just turn on your mic there you go and
just speak into it so we can hear
you thank you okay good afternoon uh
chair women and members of the children
family and law committee uh my name is
Vivian Gerard and I actually own a small
business Timber post bed and breakfast
and I've been deeply affected by uh the
child support bill um in many ways and
actually I am also speaking a week from
today on several other bills but I have
met all the New Hampshire guidelines for
child support for the last seven years
the payments uh that have that I have
received have been very
sporadic and and in nature due to the
multiple appeals of the child support
Bureau um I have not received child
support really in seven years uh when
dealing with the uh BCC bcss excuse me I
I just I want you you need to focus on
the bill at hand and the subject matter
of that bill so regarding how um
1396 right
explicit date on it would have you know
how that would affect your case well I
was trying to give you the background so
I can kind of tie that together okay if
if that's okay sure okay um when dealing
with the bcss the support payments that
I should have had should have been
immediate um as I say iMed immediate I
mean I've been going on for seven years
and I still have not seen a full child
support payment from my ex uh the speed
of the the bureau the bureau bureaucracy
should not dictate provided basic for
one CH one's children I have been forced
on several occasions to depend on the TA
taxpayers of the State of New Hampshire
to cover for the unnecessary shortfalls
because of the delay in the child
support I have not received any support
payments for December 2021 at all as
well as January
2022 when we got the order it was
actually October 25th and as of today I
still have not received any child
support at all uh the payer stops paying
for for he does he he he stops paying
for any inconceivable reasons um
enforcing the child support for
non-payment and following up on the arar
I miss three payments the court
shall it should be after three payments
the court shall garnish their wages
discretion will no longer be appropriate
after three times before Dela um
effectively affirmed into C's decision
then Dela undercut the child support
guidelines eliminated and dismissing
about $75,000 in AAR in my
case uh the judge have IND Discretions
on the child's report caused the past
seven years of arrar in my case to be
eliminated it simply seems that the
judge just didn't want to do the math
and simply simply focus on the New Order
moving forward causing to me to lose 75%
of the child support arear in August
2021 Mr Silva at the time my ex um asked
the court to actually
reduce his support down to
$192 a month for two children with no
AAR while earning
$150,000 and again I I understand that
and please pardon my Interruption but
I'm not sure what this has to do with
this bill okay do you know what I'm
saying I do like this bill simply wants
to change to make it so that an actual
due date is on the order and that's so
just to show you this binder here okay
came from my court date on August
9th my attorney my uh judge at the time
was Dela Dela gave my ex a date to start
paying child support on which was the
1 of November so we had a date he had a
date but nobody is holding him
accountable on that date and even by
going to the child's support Bureau that
date does not exist because he pays when
he wants when he wants and as much as he
feels like and I and I trust me okay I
totally understand that okay I have two
adult children I'm still old over
$770,000 wor of child support but what
I'm saying they don't have a date on it
then how do they pay if there is no
accountability on that date
do you yeah I just I just want to make
sure I'm understanding this yeah thank
you uh thank you for taking the question
um it seems to me that your testimony
set is that you had a date
um but the enforcement of the DAT or the
lack of enforcement of the date
is why you believe that it's not that
this bill maybe isn't going to fix the
problem because you're is that is that
the because there's no enforcement of
that I believe that yes I believe that
that is correct that even though you say
that there's a date on there that date
because nobody's holding the holding the
the pay accountable that date really
does not exist and this is only a third
of the of the paperwork to show that the
judges all along the my case for the
last seven years has not been held
accountable for dates they would just
write orders with
no W with no accountability on the other
side so here I am seven years
later depending on what judge you went
to you might get a date you might not
get a date if you go to the child
support Bureau then you may have a date
but nobody's holding them accountable
for those dates so even if you say put a
date on the paper that doesn't mean
anything
okay so here I am you know seven years
later and not getting any child support
even though that there was
documentation okay I get it now I was
confused okay I wasn't sure where this
was going yeah it's very confusing
because it has been seven years in the
Mak many of the laws that are coming out
next week actually apply because of my
case and because the the judge um was
not following the laww at the very
beginning which also complicated my
whole case so are you
testifying in support or in opposition
of this
bill um I am actually in support of
having a date that it that they can hold
accountable it's no good if they're not
accountable okay representative
ler thank you madam chair and thank you
for being here and I appreciate your
testimony um
so basically what you're saying is you
want us to put in a due date with the
ability to hold somebody accountable
correct correct because this just says a
due date correct okay so what I would
like to see is if as you go through
court and you actually have an order
that there's some time frame after that
they they're expected to pay not three
months
later thank you for your clarification
thank you madam chair for letting me
answer the question okay thank you thank
you very are there any further
questions okay thank you very
much okay so I have no other paint
cards does anybody have a paint card no
for this bill okay all right so I'll
close the hearing on
1286 and um
I mean 1396 I
apologize and we'll be back at 2 for
e
okay good afternoon we are back and I am
opening the public hearing on HB
1286 and um I'm recognizing ing
representative Amanda Balden to speak to
her
bill hello again
hi um I'm man balen representing
Hillsboro District 12 um to me this is
housekeeping Bill the legislature wrote
this list with the intent of confining
the changes any changes to the parenting
plan to the issues on this list um which
is uh I gave my copy away but uh one
what is
it 461
A1 you got it 461
A1 so that's the list that I'm referring
to um there's been the the much more
decision and more recently the H what
was their
name I forgot the other name oh Kelly um
and in both situations it seems like the
trial court
um modified the parenting plan outside
of the reasons listed in 461 a11 and um
then when they went to the Supreme Court
the Supreme Court said the legislature
intended for the changes to be confined
to the reasons listed here and
um and so the uh changes to the
parenting plan were undone by the
Supreme Court and so it's pretty clear
that between 2009 and 2017 which were
the two cases that I mentioned that went
to the Supreme Court there's been this
long-standing issue of trial courts not
necessarily understanding that they have
to make changes that are confined to the
list um and that they can't really go
outside of that and I think that a small
change in wording could clarify that
issue um for the courts and for people
that you know for attorneys for people
that are filing
a and she just nods at you she's like
yeah yeah um and then I think that
Additionally you know relying on case
law is bad governance um it needs to be
entered into the statute it needs to be
clarified in statute we have case law
because legislatures are are unclear um
so this is our opportunity to clear this
issue up and um additionally seeing as
this issue keeps coming up over and over
and taking to the Supreme Court level
that tells me that um there's a need for
clarification and that there may be many
people who don't have the means or the
will to take something to the Supreme
Court who are not being served in the
way that the RSA originally
intended
um and then I
guess let me look at my
notes I think overall this is just
another opportunity to reduce the case
load in the court system because if we
say here's why you can file um and
that's actually respected then uh
there'd be less
Shenanigans thank you representative
yella thank you thank you uh and thank
you for taking the
question
it seems to me that in your
testimony that it's the lower courts
that have the conclusion the the
confusion and
the Supreme Court has corrected them and
they
should now that they have that
correction and that clarification there
should not be any more confusion
so it doesn't seem like you are trying
to change anything policy-wise in New
Hampshire this
is this is the law and the Supreme Court
even says so and so I'm
questioning
that if this bill is necessary because
any confusion in the courts has been
clear cleared up by the Supreme Court at
this point
thanks for the question so I think if it
were 2010 and the much more decision had
just come down from the Supreme Court
you could say we figured this out we
don't need this but then it happened
again in 2017 with the Kelly V I don't
remember the other name but I included
that in your packet in the info packet
it's the last um Supreme Court decision
in the info packet the fact that it
happened again in 2017 so we have two
cases that went all the way to Supreme
Court on this issue which makes me think
that there must be a lot more at the
trial court level that never went to the
Supreme Court where the confusion
persists and you know this was only four
or five years
ago so I I I guess that's what I'm
saying is that it's happening
repetitively therefore it's on us to
clarify the legislative intent by
rewarding it slightly instead of relying
on each independent trial court to and
judge to figure it
out through case law
I hope that makes sense follow up yes
thank you um do you know offand the
reasons that the
modifications uh without reading the
entire um thing right now um why the me
modifications happened and um or the
reason given for them that wasn't part
of the
list are you talking about in the two
Supreme Court cases yes
um it's it was complex it was
complicated for me to read um but
they're they're not that hard to find if
you want to skim the the um conclusions
from the Supreme Court are
pretty obviously notated it would take a
lot for me to find it right now on the
hot seat fine thank
you any further
questions
seeing none thank you very much thanks
I'm out of your hair now well have a
great rest of your
day is there anyone else that wanted to
testify that has filled out a pain
card okay seeing none I'm closing the
hearing on House Bill 1286 and we will
be back at 2:30 that was a click
one
e
okay good afternoon we're back um I'm
gonna open the public hearing on HB
1382 and representative Jim kofalt will
speak for three minutes in support of
his
bill
thank you madam chairwoman um as is uh
summarized in the first section of the
bill um one key purpose of this bill is
to establish a presumption of shared
parenting and currently RSA 461 A6
establishes the criteria upon which
parenting time should be allocated and
this includes things like the best
interest of the child the ability for
the parent to provide adequate food
shelter Etc that will not change under
this
bill I would like to point out that um
RSA 461 A2 currently states that the new
state of New Hampshire uh has a policy
that unless it is clearly shown that in
a particular case it is detrimental to a
child um then it is best to have both
parents have a stable and meaningful
involvement in the children's lives um
and therefore we should support frequent
and continuing contact between each
child and both parents and encourage
parents to share in the rights and
responsibilities of raising their
children having said that the current
law although it implies that both
parents should be involved or it
explicitly States both should be
involved um it does not explicitly U say
that the default should be 5050 shared
parenting and that's the the primary
purpose of this bill um this would be a
rebuttable Pres assumption in other
words if the court finds any cause to
allocate custody differently that option
is always open and there are certainly
cases where that would be appropriate
unfortunately uh the bill also provides
equal access to records including for
example school and medical records again
the court May rule
otherwise the bill also gives uh
substantial weight to the input of a
mature child 14 years or older um it
changes the language in the existing
statute that would um that would allow
for a child of any age to State a
preference as to which parent they
prefer to uh to spend more time with or
or have as their primary primary U
custody um this will reduce the extent
to which children are used as Pawns in
uh battles between the parents um this
is a very damaging
phenomenon um it is uh it's unfortunate
it is uh psychologically tormenting for
children and um by uh by focusing on
mature children 14 years or older and
changing it from preference to input um
our expectation is that this could
reduce the extent to which children are
are uh used as Pawns in the middle of
that battle finally this bill clarifies
the fact that a child if if a child is
homeschooled that shall not be the sole
factor in determining whether uh
parental parental rights and
responsibilities should be allocated
differently than
otherwise um so that is the uh summary
of the of of House Bill
1382 and I uh I'm prepared to take
questions if there are any from the
committee okay are there any questions
for representative of
kofalt Representative Banger thank you
madam chair and thank you representative
kall for coming today um um so looking
at this I I kind of have uh mixed
feelings about the way to give
substantial weight to the uh on line 24
on page two um specifically it says at
least and at least 14 years old as
bolded uh the court May uh give
substantial weight to the input of the
mature minor
child now members of this committee we
often hear as members of as members of
this committee we often hear a lot that
judges give a they have a little bit too
much judicial oversight
or discretion discretion thank you uh I
apologize I couldn't find that word so
um I kind of foresee that as an issue
and I want to kind of personally I've
seen that as an issue and I kind of want
to scope that and bring that down a
little bit um have you
take
have you taken into consideration the
potential of that specific language to
be a possibility that it it could add
more judicial discretion to the judge's
decision-making
process that's an interesting point and
I think one that that could certainly be
considered we could look at potential
ways to uh to to rephrase or modify that
um I think the the the concern that led
to this proposed change in the in the
language
um is
that asking a young child in particular
to State a preference
[Music]
um is I think a you know a commonly used
tactic when parents are trying to sort
of pit the child against the other
parent and that this kind of encourages
a a damaging um kind of behavior among
the parents um having said that I hear
your concern I I think it's it's a valid
concerned that um there's quite a lot of
latitude in in many of these
cases um in fact you know one of the
things that this bill would do would be
to um require the court to to to provide
substantiation for any deviation from
50-50 parenting so in in a lot of
respects I see this as a bill that's
intended to um to clarify and provide
guidance um rather than
providing perhaps too much lat attitude
so I I think it's a valid concern U but
I think it's also it's offsetting
another very very important concern
about uh what's happening to children in
a lot of these
cases follow
up the other thing that I was um
wondering is why you decide thank you
for answering the question I greatly
appreciate it sorry about that um is
what decision making went into the the
effective
date and I asked that because
I like to see something take effect
after 60 days for example to um give the
Court's substantial time but not enough
substantial time where it's taking too
long for that to um to take
effect I'm certainly open to to seeing
that change I I I think the idea there
really is that you know this this will
there will be some time required for for
the courts to adjust to the new law and
to adopt that in in their cases so I I
just I think uh you know it's it's not
one of these laws that could probably be
uh implemented immediately 60 days might
be appropriate um I I think it it could
easily be
changed thank you no further question
are there any other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you very
much up next is representative Lisa post
to speak in support of the bill and she
has written testimony but she didn't
tell me how long she need it darn
it my name is Lisa post and I'm here
today to CO as a co-sponsor of House
Bill
1382 relative to the presumption of
shared parenting and I ask for your
support on this much-needed bill over
the past several months I've heard
testimony from many New Hampshire
parents regarding uh their children who
have been negatively impacted by the
family court system that clearly does
not have the best interest of the child
at heart in
consideration of shared
parenting the recent news events
regarding the behavior of judges and
Guardian ad lims has shown the system
has failed many families it's undeniable
that the current situation of the family
court system is in need of repair our
children are the most important part of
our Lives when the family unit breaks
apart and results in custody issues it
is in the child's best
interest to continue a healthy nurturing
relationship with both parents starting
with the presumption of equal parenting
it's time for our legislature to act and
I'm asking you to support House Bill
1382 and thank you for your time
today thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you up next is representative David love
to speak in support of the bill for
three
minutes thank you madam chair thank you
committee members uh I'm here in as a
co-sponsor and and strong support of
this bill uh you know some some personal
experiences uh after getting divorced
and uh you know uh you know I've got a
22y old daughter that uh certainly could
have benefited by this uh you know she's
uh my exwife when we were getting
divorced she said oh she's resilient
she'll get over it she's 22 years old
and she's still in therapy she's still a
mess um you know I've got a a I had a
nephew that uh you know his his mother
probably would have have been judged uh
you know the would have would have
fallen into the the category of it's
better off she didn't but uh just losing
a parent for him at 30 years old he
never got over it you know and he put a
gun to his head a year ago you know um
you know the these things are ongoing
problems you know for for for the kids
you know kids need both parents you know
and and if it's at all possible uh we
need to we need to make sure that the
judges don't uh use their discretion
wrongly you know uh they're human beings
and when they they if they get a bad
case where you know one parent has uh
has beaten the children or whatever uh
you know you're not going to tell me
that the next five cases AR influenced
by it and uh you know because they are
only human they're tired they're overow
worked um and um you know we need we
need to give them strong guidelines you
know reel in that J judicial uh judicial
um discretion
discretion I have a hard time
remembering it to but uh you know if we
give them uh you know strict guidelines
on on how to do things uh I I think you
know Society Society will be be better
for it uh you know a lot of a lot of the
broken family is a lot of what Al
society today you know um you know we've
got uh you know kids that are on all
kind all kinds of different medicines uh
you know because they're you know
they're depressed ADH you know whatever
you know uh take away take away a parent
the one that's supposed to be supposed
to be their protector I'm supposed to be
on their side they've only got half
their team now you know uh it never has
a good you know a good outcome and uh
you know we've got to we've got to start
changing that it's Our obligation to do
that and uh I hope uh hope you guys um
vote this thing o OTP uh you know an
amendment here or there that uh is fine
by me but um you know it's something
kids need you know it's all about the
kids thanks thank you are there any
questions seeing n thank you very
much
up next is Gail drat to speak in support
of the bill for three
minutes open do you have written
testimony yes oh she has written
testimony too I have to let him know
because then he can add it to the record
without having to take crazy notes
okay thank you madam chair thank you
members of the committee for the
opportunity to testify before you today
each of you as our elected policy makers
have the greatest ability to reform
outdated laws to better protect children
and families of New Hampshire I come
before you in support of House Bill
1382 my name is Gail drat I'm I am
advocating for mothers and fathers who
will come before the family court system
this bill provides equality for both
parents to have a meaningful
relationship with their children it also
provides only with clear and convincing
evidence with the judge will the judge
deviate from shared parenting these
judges are deciding fundamental rights
of children and their parents these
decisions impact fames lives
forever our state already recognizes
that frequent and continued contact is
in the child's best interest shared
parenting 182.5 days with each parent
with clear and convincing evidence and
fact findings and conclusions of law
protects a meaningful relationship with
both parents this bill will reduce
litigation family case filings and false
reportings of domestic violence or abuse
this bill will reduce conflict if you
know going into a separation of divorce
that shared parenting is the standard
under current New Hampshire laws we
recognize that children do best when
both parents have a stable and
meaningful involvement in their lives it
also States in part unless clearly shown
that in a particular case it is
detrimental to a child this state will
support frequent and continued contact
with each child and both parents
encourage parents to share in the rights
and responsibilities of raising their
children and parents to develop their
own parenting
plan this to me implies shared parenting
and clear evidence this is not what is
happening in the New Hampshire family
court system children are being denied
equal access in a lot of cases and they
are
denied access some are denied ass access
at all um with no substantial EV oh my
God I can't talk
evidence of abuse or neglect children
are going months and years with no
contact with parents parents are having
to walk away from their children due to
the adversarial nature of Family Court
created by poor orders attorneys
extending litigation for billable hours
the court forcing parents to engage with
biased Court Affiliated and ordered
Guardian at Liams and therapists the
state has no legal reason to treat
either parent differently a father no
less than a mother has a tionally
protected right to the companionship
care custody and management of their
children if we do not legislate clearer
laws that better protect the
Constitutional fundamental rights of
parents New Hampshire children will
continue to be failed by A system that
is supposed to protect them we must look
to studies and not ideology there are
Decades of research that confirms shared
parenting and that both parents being
involved in the everyday obligations of
parenting is the best interest standard
these obligations require that neither
parent be relegated to an every other
weekend parent that merely makes them
one parent a visitor in the lives of
their children and defies
constitutionally protected rights and
state statute laws that afford children
the right to frequent and continued
contact with both parents with least
restrictive means by affording either
parent anything less than 5050 shared
parenting the least restrictive means
are not being applied although some say
Kentucky shared parenting Bill may have
flaws we must recognize that they
pioneered the first true shared
parenting Bill Kentucky has paved the
way in the right direction to protect
Children and Families it has been
documented that shared parenting has
lessened domestic violence parental
conflict and has led to a decline in
case filings with family court I come to
you as a mother and an aunt who has not
seen her nephew in four years my
children have not seen their cousin and
my mother has not seen her grandson and
more importantly my nephew has not seen
his father this is unnecessary trauma to
all children
involved unnecessary trauma and abuse to
my nephew that has had to mourn the loss
of his entire family that are very much
alive and that he was very close to this
is unnecessary trauma on my brother
warning the loss of his son this will
have lifelong effects to the overall
mental emotional well-being of these
children and our entire family my family
member has shared had shared parenting
shared expenses and Joint decision
making for eight plus years mom started
a new relationship and started
interrupting that schedule moved the
minor child out of town and school
district with approximately a week's
notice via text 2017 the mother withheld
50% of parenting time and she has
willfully withheld the minor child since
February 1st of 2018 the court the court
did not order temporary visitation and
there was no hearing held for 10 months
allowing continued interference with
custody this School continues to violate
parental rights and not provide dad
school documents and records of the
child's behaviors my family member went
to the family court for Relief to
protect his son and their relationship
in a timely manner the court did not
recognize he was the moving party and it
would be impossible that the E that his
pleadings were even read We are failing
New Hampshire children by removing or
limiting access to a parent without
clear and convincing evidence of abuse
or neglect which brings me to the false
allegations false reporting to police
false reports to DCF interference with
custody these are criminal codes in the
state and continue to be ignored no one
is enforcing the laws that have already
been
legislated statistically fathers of the
of the parent relegated to the
non-custodial parent in a visitor in
their child's life we are failing as a
society at ethic rates by removing
parents from the lives of their children
this is unclear United States
Constitution new Hamp New Hampshire
Constitution state laws and Supreme
Court protects the rights of parents and
children the courts are emotionally
traumatizing children and families and
the courts are draining financial
resources of parents with no relief or
contact with their children the lack of
judicial oversight is is allowing these
Court officials to violate their
judicial cannons codes of professional
conduct with no
repercussions thank you for your time
and I pray you all vote in favor of this
important bill and we reform outdated
statutes to better protect the rights
safety and well-being of New Hampshire
children thank you um so I have a
question yes you had stated that he had
50% custody she moved
and does he still have a parenting plan
that's 5050 and he's not seeing them or
what has happened did the courts change
that are the C courts not holding her
they've done
nothing so they had a 2009 court order
they never used they came up with an
implemented a 5050 shared parenting plan
they used that for eight years was that
on paper and signed by a judge no that's
why he can't get access to the record he
can't even no because he still has joint
decision even from the 2009 but the
school is not allowing him the
pediatrician won't send him and this kid
has had has horrific things that I don't
want to get into because it's one thing
I'm going to say to you even if you have
an agreement doesn't matter go get it
signed by a judge you know because you
can follow that agreement for 10 years
and someone gets in a mood right right
but they're not sh they're not even
following the court order and the courts
haven't done anything nothing they won't
even
address his emotional mental state right
now is bad
okay thank you are there any further
questions right seea thank you very
much okay up next is um Brenda town to
speak in support of the bill for three
minutes and do you have written
testimony I do she does this an easy day
for
you
so I'd like to thank this committee and
the chairman for um hearing us today and
I'm here to ask your support on HB
1382 um again my name is Brenda town and
I am a mother of four kids and a
grandmother of eight children and in
2018 um my family uh
experienced um the trauma of Family
Court um my middle a my th um ended up
uh in a very contentious divorce
situation where the infamous Silver
Bullet uh with false accusations of
abuse and crimes were used as leverage
to Pro to uh position in um The Family
Court environment um the good news is
that after six months of not seeing um
the grandchildren and his kids we were
able to work our way through those
things but it was incredibly uh
traumatized iing to my family and to the
children and to him he had been an
Engaged dad um uh honorably discharged
Marine um actively involved no history
of abuse and yet when he entered into
Family Court when he went to seek
parenting uh time for his kids he was
immediately hamstrung on trying to get
shared parenting and with that it it it
created a an unlikely passionate parent
advocate in me and I became the leader
of a parent um organization here in New
Hampshire for parents who were
struggling with uh the family court
issues with over 5,000 uh folks uh
participating and following us on
Facebook um I would on a daily basis
help these parents who would message me
and um really help them try to triage
their situation and in most all of the
cases where they were suffering the most
was in regards to this shared parenting
they were struggling because they wanted
to be actively engaged in their kids'
lives but um they had to fight it became
kind of a beauty contest if you will
when they went into Family Court where
they were trying to position themselves
to be an equal participant as a parents
so they could see their kids on an equal
basis so with my exposure to all of this
it I it also led me I am now the
director of the um National Parents
organization here in New Hampshire where
I I do work with parents who are
struggling with uh issues and again the
uh issue around parenting time is
tantamount with the research shows us
and it's very clear that these
households that are broken um if we can
maintain equal parenting time for our
kids uh with equal quality time with
their parents we will create an outcome
in those kids that is most like intact
families there's uh less depression less
anxiety more success at school less
teenage pregnancy these things are an
outcome of meaningful participation of
two parents in our current situation it
is ambiguous when a family goes in on
how that parenting plan will land and
because of that gray area it leaves us
open to very large times of litigation
which set a foundation of acrimony that
linger through the rest of the time that
those kids have to to be raised and
parented between um the two parents so
this bill would remove the um ambiguous
nature it would allow for standards with
discretion um as well documented by our
judges if they need to deviate from this
which is very important for families
today in family court because that does
not exist when um a decision is made in
all cases so very important for them the
other thing that I wanted to leave you
with is that in 2018 we do have have an
example in Kentucky where they passed a
5050 shared parenting bill it's the
oldest example we have and this bill
within one year reduced family court
cases by 11% because parents no longer
had to fight on their way in the door it
helped resolve that issue for them the
other interesting thing which ties
directly into my family story is 10% of
all the domestic violence uh cases were
dropped as well because there was no no
longer um the necessity of a tool to
position position yourself um as the
stronger parent in entering family court
and so again um we just ask your support
for this bill to remedy this very clear
outline of what shared parenting should
be unless there is a meaningful reasons
why it shouldn't be 50-50 shared
parenting and we ask that you will help
us close this Gap so that our kids in
this state have access to both parents
and we create the healthiest future
citizens of New Hampshire we possibly
can thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing n thank you very much
thank
you up next is Shea
Sheila uh
gther that's going to be read by Eric
brand is is that right yes okay and
you've asked for uh five
minutes thank you madam chair and
committee members my name is Eric
Brandon I'll be reading this letter um
that was given to me to share today um
dear children and family law committee
Representatives I am strongly in support
of HB 1382 from 2022 an act relative to
the presumption of shared parenting in
the determination of parental rights and
responsibilities as a licensed clinical
mental health counselor for close to 20
years I have treated several women and
men who have been subject to poor and
bias decisions from the family courts in
all cases if there had been a
presumption for Shared Parenting the
pain inflicted on the targeted parent
and children would not have occurred and
would not have left scar life life left
lifetime scars the lifetime scars
including several
alternating several alienating
relationships a child or children have
had with a responsible loving parent in
other words using a child or children as
a weapon against a targeted parent in
all cases there were guardi lims
involved that for all intents and
purposes appeared biased against the
targeted parent unfortunately in most of
the cases it was the parent who could
also not afford adequate with legal
representation Andor ability to pay part
of the Guardian liem fee that was
targeted in treating adults involved in
these types of cases the harm that is
done is very difficult to repair
especially when unfair custody decis
custody decisions are made in many cases
due to biased or blatant lies regarding
the targeted parent while the gals in
the court would not consider the
evidence presented showing what was said
Etc where blatant lies or biased
opinions is difficult to comprehend in
addition to the targeted parent in
addition the targeted parent suffers
profound grief over the loss of time
with a child or children which can
evolve into full-blown depressive
episodes requiring medication and
therapy to resolve to an acceptable
level in several cases women and men
were emotionally or verbally abused by
the other party with evidence of such
submitted to the court and still the
court decided in favor of the the abuser
and ignored the evidence in at least
three cases there was direct evidence of
Parental alienation there was also
evidence of undesirable and improper
influences such as influences that was
also ignored in the Court's decision in
all cases the children were offered
material Goods that targeted the parent
that could not afford and thus
manipulating the children to side
against the targeted parent they were
also offered fund vacations expens
expensive Electronics pets and sports of
their choice Etc these actions taken by
the other party truly constitute child
abuse due to the long-term damage that
is done both to how the child will
mature in the dis Distortion done to the
previous loving relationship they had
with the targeted parent shared
parenting would certainly help to
mitigate conflict and as research has
shown even in cases where there's high
conflict in the divorce or custody
proceedings the children continue to do
well in shared parenting situations
versus sole custody
shared parenting treats both parents as
equal and eliminates children from being
treated as property to be fought over
and shared parenting children will
continue to build strong attachment
bonds with both parents leading to
better mental health outcomes later in
life the exception to using the
presumption of shared parenting would be
in cases where there is domestic
violence child abuse of any kind severe
drug drug addiction untreat treated
mental illness or other criminal
activity which would negatively impact
the welfare of a child or children
respectfully submitted Sheila Gunther
okay thank you um
[Music]
so I was under the assumption you were
going to be reading for someone that was
here that was perhaps too emotional to
to be able to speak I just want to make
it clear that in the future I will not
accept someone reading someone else's
testimony who is not here because we
cannot question that person we did
receive an email from this person so so
they've testified but what'll happen is
next week I'll get people coming in here
saying I need to read the testimony of
these 20 people and those are 20 people
that we cannot
question okay so that was my mistake but
I just want to set the record straight
for right now that it will not happen
again in the future okay I'm I'm Sorry
Miss Madam chair thank you it's it's not
your fault it was my fault I made an
assumption so you know what they you
know so that's my fault um so up next
will be Eric brand who is speaking for
himself right for five
minutes thank thank you madam chair and
committee members um I am here in
support of HB
1382 I'm a lifelong resident of New
Hampshire I've been a business over
business owner for over 30 years I
volunteer regularly in the community I'm
the chair of a state committee here in
conquer I coach and I've also been
recognized this at the Town state and
National level with awards for my
business most importantly I'm the father
of three I have a 25 24 year old 22y old
and a 17y old my 22y old has multiple
disabilities which I won't get into
today but I've been a fierce Advocate at
the state level uh and locally and
within the schools for that
child the current standard as most of us
are aware are that one parent 80% of the
time ends up being the father that is
only Ed in every other weekend type
visitation with the child or
children typically the judge will award
this as a standard and tries to pick the
best parent using Guardian items or
maybe uh that particular individual had
a bad day in court when they went to
represent or couldn't have legal
representation to help get them a 50-50
shared
parenting when parents are together they
both contribute how the child is raised
their values beliefs and help mold a
child into little versions of
themselves which we all hope they take
the best qualities from each parent some
parents will nurture some will teach
some are quiet some are outspoken some
watch TV some teach Adventure some cook
some teach how to change attire at the
end of the day as one we are the best
when one parent only shares 10% of that
child's time the children doesn't get
the opportunity to become
whole I was a victim of the every other
weekend parent plan when I was a child
some 30 years ago to this day I still
believe that my relationship with my
father is still tarnished we've tried to
repair it we still still spend time
together but it never feels like that
same connection of a bond that I strive
to have with my own children especially
my 17-year-old which I spent a
tremendous amount of time with since he
is still the one that is is we're
working on with it a current child uh
parenting
plan my son is now becoming that same
victim that I
was so now my son misses time with me
that is only allowed by the other parent
when she chooses to De deviate from the
parent plan he's missing school
vacations with me Summertime with me
certain holidays all of those are
dictated by the other
parent I've struggled to try to make
sure as a father that under these
circumstances my relationship stays
strong with my son and that my bond with
my child children are not affected in
the same way mine
was I support this bill so I can help
end the struggle that many parents
continue to go through we must end this
cycle that the nation not just New
Hampshire but the nation has of having
these divisive situations
this bill will help keep children
whole now to give you a quick little
story I'm the kind of parent that
attends IEP meetings I do homework with
my children I go to every parent teacher
conference open houses teach how to do
laundry cook go car shopping and teach
car maintenance I've hiked 38 of the 48
New Hampshire 4,000 Footers I've visited
18 national parks I go camping biking
run 5Ks triathlons teach golfing to my
children teach them how to volunteer and
continue to be active in the community
teach them Personal Care I've coached I
attend every sporting event for my
children and as I've mentioned before
I'm a fierce Advocate with disabilities
and I've spoken at the State House on
behalf of disabilities many times am I
truly with that description a parent
that should only have 10% of the time
with my children unfortunately this is
what happens to many many parents out
there
and and I support part of that bill that
even speaks in the that this should be
presumption from the when the temp
orders are given I've been going through
a court battle for over three and a half
years when my son I think he was 14 at
the time so very formative years from 14
to 18 that he's missing out on having me
side by side and making sure he's going
the right line I try and I try to make
sure that I'm there with
him previously I'm not sure if it was
very clear but two states have passed
this shared parenting law back in 1990
the state of New Hampshire led the
nation in closing it State schools
institutions for those with disabilities
we led the way in 1990 in changing how
the nation thinks we must once again do
that be number three in passing this
bill so that we can change how the rest
of the nation continues to think parents
should not have to fight for the
constitutional rights to be in their
children's lives
thank you thank you are there any
questions seeing none thank you thank
you up next is Dana
alre to speak in support of the bill for
three
minutes thank you Madame chairm my name
is Dana albre I'm a resident of new
nashille New Hampshire please forgive me
if I appear a little nervous this is my
first time ever testifying no worries
before uh I'm a father of four children
uh two uh boys who are presently age 24
and 21 and two girls who are presently
age 17 and
15 um my family case has been family law
case has been ongoing five years since
April 8th
2016 it's received both coverage in the
New Hampshire union leader and uh
National coverage um that's the handout
is not my testimony it's just in support
oh okay I'm like what is this this not
testimony don't spend a lot of time
reading that right
now
uh so I've been in this my family's been
in the system five years since uh April
8th
2016 with countless different judges uh
uh I just now got uh yet another new
judge uh and he just got even appointed
as a judge uh six months ago so uh any
bills that can make his life easier are
a good thing because uh even he's new
with
this uh just a brief background on my
case uh and then I'll speak to the
particulars of the
bill uh so uh prior to that I had judge
Paul Moore and judge incasso who were
both uh later uh charged with felonies
and are now Off the
Bench uh judge in traso appointed her
best friend Kathleen sternenberg as G in
my case I'm one of the nine cases in
which he did that as a conflict of
interest and that's the handout I'm sure
you can look at it
later um Master Del pra
was aware of that conflict since
2014 didn't notify
me
um moving
forward uh Master uh Dow pra concerning
my family CA law case said in open court
who gives an
FK concerning testimoni and evidence
yeah that's me uh and called my kids
morons uh and again all that's kind of
in the union leader if the committee
wants those articles I can get them to
you but I don't have them with me
today
um so less about judicial
misconduct but there's plenty of good
judges out there honest judges out there
and we need to make their lives easy
with good legislation
that they can figure out and lessens
their
workload so the way things work in
family court right now is a lot of the
proceedings are really about who's the
quote better
parent and if you go to a lot of Court
hearings they'll devolve into the
ridiculous like whether Mom put matching
kids on the socks to go to school
whether peanut butter and jelly or smoke
sand in is better as a sandwich and just
stuff that has no place in deciding
custody because they make it about who's
the better parent and that's just
wrong
um
so in a normal family Dynamic realizing
there's exceptions
kids naturally want to love both parents
both parents naturally love their
children their children want to have a
positive relationship with both parents
that's the ideal even divorce is not the
ideal but if we're going to go through
it let's maintain the positive
relationship with both parents and have
a presumption of
that um this would have
gone
just a tremendous this way towards
preventing the tragedy of my case I mean
we've been in the system five
years
and the guardian ad lium Kathleen
sternenberg decided it would be in the
best interest of my daughters both of
whom were born in nashille and new H
excuse me in New Hampshire to relocate
to Pasadena
California at the time my daughter's 8
years old at the time
um and uh Kathleen sternenberg decided
she was a mature minor according to the
current statute and that that would
carry all the weight because she liked
her California
Vacations so she should move there can I
ask you a really quick question um was
that a recommendation she made to the
judge uh yes I can also what year was
that uh the hearing was in
2017 something I'd like to provide the
committee I only have one copy with me
today but I can submited after the fact
is the written transcript of Mr
stenberg's testimony in my case or at
least make that available to the
committee so I guess my question is did
did the judge ask her a question or did
she write a recommendation she wrote a
recommendation thank
you
uh so since that
time uh my kids have relocated multiple
times first from Hollis New Hampshire
then to Sierra Madre California then to
Pasadena California and most recently to
East China
Michigan uh all as a consequence of her
recommendation um and that's LED rise to
A multi-state diversity of citizenship
family law case Under the UCC J EA for
enforcement so now we've got an
enforcement Docket in California we've
got an enforcement Docket in Michigan
and then we have the primary docket here
because New Hampshire retains primary
jurisdiction and all of this could have
been prevented with a simple
presumption of shared
parenting and over the course of the
past five years I've maybe gotten to see
my younger kids a total of 30 40 days
because they keep moving and the courts
you know again some of these corrupt
judges have been simply unwilling to
enforce even the parenting plan they
gave
me if I could ask um at some point could
you send me a copy of that um the gal
recommendation that she wrote absolutely
thank
you
uh so one of the things I want to speak
to on the bill itself which is echoing
some of Brenda Town's testimony that
really hit
home is let's face it I'm in a high
conflict
divorce and if there's
a presumption that the parents are just
going to get equal parenting time to
begin with again
presumption then that's going to cut
down tremendously on parents efforts to
manipulate kids into favoring one parent
over the
other uh I think the quantitative
evidence that the committee heard
earlier supports that it's really going
to cut down on a lot of the things we
heard earlier about you know one parent
trying to get a kid on their side you
know with expensive gifts you name it
vacations if we just start out with the
no you know you're getting the kids
equal time absent a compelling clear and
convincing reason why that's not a good
idea just cuts down on conflict in
families
um and sort of when we have all this
conflict with kids trying to to
manipulate parents trying to manipulate
kids into spending more time with one
parent or the
other uh then that's just extremely
emotionally damaging to the kids and you
know I've lived it yeah so I I just
think having this would really cut down
on the efforts it makes lives easier for
the judges to just kind of go yeah no
this is what we're doing unless
somebody's got some clear and convincing
evidence otherwise um how much time do I
have left oh I wasn't really counting
but we don't want to go on forever
because you start to your audience am I
am I am done but I could speak to one
other portion of the bill Depending on
time go right ahead
uh which uh forgive me one moment let me
find it
here uh so we spoke to the at least
14year old part which I think is very
important we spoke to equal
parenting uh I'd like to speak to the
part except as otherwise
cuded uh professional public or private
institution organization denies access
to records I just wanted to say that's
been a huge problem in my case and it's
been exacerbated because we're dealing
with
multi-state stuff and because I was
going to say I mean I'm not sure how
much we canfor Force anything from
another state to another state um I
think under the ucj we can but what's
coming out of New Hampshire right now is
really confusing
orders simply because there's so much
discretion and so much crazy on the
socks and the the salmon
sandwiches and these huge narrative
orders and a judge from another state
you know they eyes glaze
over and so if we can get nice simple
clean orders with nice simple clean
legislation then a judge from another
state an enforcement can go oh yeah I
get
it and we're all set um I think that
concludes the remarks I'd like to make
uh happy to follow up later with
anything written and certainly would
like to take questions if anyone has any
are there any questions
representative
Banger thank you and um thank you madam
chair and thank you for your testimony
I'm so sorry for what you having to deal
with but thank you to to your comment
about um judicial discretion yes I
brought up on page two line 24 through
25 mention that to give substantial
weight to and and
if if I may it sounds like you support
the way that that's worded I support it
because it would have been a massive
improvement over deciding that my
8-year-old was a mature or minor and
because she liked her California
vacations at Disneyland that California
C would be a good place to
move follow up so M
Mike I feel for you yeah and I think
there's a better way that we can deal
with this and deal with your situation
but I I don't think the language is the
way that it should be done because what
it's saying and you are you are exactly
right you saying that your 14-year-old
swayed by Mom's opinion
eight-year-old yeah in in this case
saying that you're 14-year-old I
understand eight but your 14 a
14-year-old in this situation comes
forward and is swayed by Mom's
persuasion that they want to move that
the judge can still make consideration
to that person's persuasion so that's I
I want so do you understand where I'm
coming from yes and in fact I completely
agree with you sir and so we may have a
issue of how best to accomplish what
we're trying to accomplish and I think
we're in agreement there
and uh so if there are suggestions for
amendments to do an even better job of
this then I would certainly support that
thank you and I was just going to ask
you that thank you yeah no further
questions thank you there any other
questions all right seeing none thank
you very much thank you madam chairman
and please be sure that I get
that uh yes thank
you up next is Angela
losier um she needs five minutes to
speak in support of the bill and has
written testimony and this is the last
pink card I
have just just be clear I will do my
best okay do you want to pass out your
if you want to just put your your test
give your testimony to her we'll pass it
around while you begin thank
you this isn't very easy for me oh can I
get one copy of that myself of course
um first time kind of doing this
uncertain of like what is allowed
keeping it short um it's okay so please
we're all just people right
um I'm
recently new out of court so let me just
read and then I'll kind of touch a few
um topics from hearing everybody else's
testimony um dear children and family
log and representatives thank you for
allowing me this opportunity to
testify before this committee on this
important bill do you know someone can
come and sit next to you if you'd like
you don't have to sit there
alone that's I I want you to know I've
been where you are I completely
understand okay and you're not alone so
we got this and you've got someone
sitting next to you okay you're going to
be okay and we're here to listen I do
my if you want if you want to have your
your seatmate read for you if you think
that would be
easier you know I just I just want to
make it easy on you no it's okay I'll
get through this but it's it's still
very fresh to me yeah um so my name is
Angela loer I am a resident and a
business owner in Conquer New
Hampshire I am the mother of one
daughter Stella who will actually be 13
tomorrow I have been the main
caregiver of Stella since
um when the relationship between her
father and I dissolved our daughter was
just a year old when I decided the
relationship was too toxic due to his
excessive drinking and emotional abuse
this wasn't an easy decision being a new
mom and still nursing at the time I knew
I it would involve sharing time between
households and not being there daily as
I once
knew I knew it wasn't going to be easy
but it was important to me that our
daughter would grow up seeing two people
love and respect each other despite the
differences we had I knew how how
important it is that both parents share
time and
responsibilities we had shared parental
rights and a scheduled that worked every
few
years I would have to engage in Family
Court
proceedings as my ex would bring me back
to court again for full
custody her father has always said
through the years he would take her away
from
me despite her father having three DUI I
always supported always supported a
parenting plan that was
fair just most recently in November
2019 my ex again engaged with a family
court to revisit the parenting plan he
continued to motion the court for G
Catherine stanburg which
was um which was unclear as there has
never been any allegation of abuse or
any neglect in my
care my daughter's father also motioned
the court for an in camera interview
with our
daughter the judge asked why he was
motioning the
court if neither one of us had been in
the Family Court since
2012 father replied my daughter wants to
live with me the marital Master replied
no 10-year-old should be in the middle
let her be a
kid after several requests the court
ordered a
gal only after manipulating my
daughter and saying things to the
appropriate people at school her
counselor to suade him to order a
gal and in my opinion and after through
court
documents cine Stenberg was less than
professional was biased it did not work
in the best interest of our
daughter recommendations were made by
the guardian at lium which removed my
daughter from my care and consequently
turned me into a primary parent to an
every other weekend mom in my child's
life this has resulted in my ex not
involving me now in medical
educational and any other
co-parenting decisions I'm being cut out
of my daughter's life because of the
Court's decision in uncooperative ex and
a
g these recommendations were
unclear as of January 1st
2019 amendments were made to RSA
461a
163 and removed
recommendations from that
statute it is
imperative that judges are educated and
updated statutes it is Bel
although relationships and marriages
sometimes do not work out this should
not be a reason to obstruct one parent
from being anything less than an equal
in the lives of our child
children children have the right to love
and be loved by both parents I know for
me the most rewarding and fulfilling
role in my life is that of a
mother I'm supporting I support HP
1982 I believe shareed parenting with
fit willing enabl parents is the best
outcome for children unless there is
convincing supporting evidence that
raises concerns related to criminal
activity such as drug abuse domestic
violence um and child abuse that would
adversely affect the well-being of a
child I thank you for listening and I
truly hope you support HB
1382 um after hear in more
about this
bill um my daughter was 10 years old
like I said when we started and it it's
been half of her life he's taken me
three
times
um she was 10 and he was like let her be
a kid um I had a guardian at lion that
sided with Dad that paid her and um
believed a lot of lies without no
evidence I have no criminal background
I've never had DCF called on me until he
wasn't getting his way in court of
course we were in Co a mother going
through the stress that she was knowing
that my daughter wanted more time with
her dad I gave
5050 without a court order and to have
somebody like Kathleen come in and say
my kid was in
danger five weeks before my final
hearing a just signed off on it did she
write that in the
recommendation and are you sure it was
2019 I thought we we did that bill
earlier because I'll tell you that bill
came about because of me because we had
recommendations from a g so I said we
decided no more recommendations from
gal's and now that I'm hearing she's
writing this and excuse me I'm very
angry I can never get back the damage
that lady's done to my
family to my relationship with my
daughter that was 10 and at the end of
it at 12 years old she said she was
mature to make a
decision no 12-year-old girl that just
started her period and can't even
understand her own emotions can decide
what's best for her even during court I
pleaded and pleaded and of course
everything was WebEx nothing's in
person um it was a difficult time I
think for a lot of families but to be
under covid your work your
homeschooling
um I
I I'm hurt and I'll never probably and
now I'm back into why I left my ex and
now he holds the power card and Kathleen
gave him that in the courts I
feel um just stamped it thinking I had
so much evidence that they didn't look
at and if they would have just stuck
with a mom that was willing to give
every weekend if there was a Monday
holiday he could have it we live an hour
apart so it's not easy I every other
week in the summer every school vacation
I never want to deny my daughter more
time with the other parent ever and then
to go from being that parent through the
young years and now and every other
weekend mom is a sentence I would rather
be a
criminal and get whatever they give me
but not to be a part of my kid's life is
the worst feeling when I got that
recommendation Kathleen made that said
my kid was in
danger I felt to the ground like my kid
I somebody came to my door and told me
she was kidnapped and who was the judge
um Thomas
Cooper I just feel like to see a copy of
the the the
recommendation ordered all my
transcripts and
audio I did she ever provide you with a
copy you should have been provided a
copy of what she gave to the court
anyways she should have provided both
parties um I didn't get her final bill
till months after when my my ex paid not
her bill I'm talking about the
recommendation that she made to the
court I can look for it
okay
that I guess is my story so for as a mom
that gave it her all and he climbed the
you know the ladder in his career and he
did he manipulated my daughter because
he wasn't being heard and then he used
my daughter to say you need to tell the
school this tell them that tell them
that I never had DCF at my house I never
had cops at my house I was abused too
and I don't testify good as you can tell
tell this is very intimidating for me um
because it reminds me of a it's very
emotional and I understand yeah I
understand I I understand Court PTSD it
it's um I'm still healing and you know
to to support this takes a lot because I
want to put my head in the in in the
sand but I if my situation doesn't
change of course I'm devastated I don't
want another family to go through
through this and I feel like if it
wasn't a battle like half of my
daughter's life has been spend in court
or the parents and then it's like every
few years we made six and a half years I
I mean to ask my kid to get in a court
when she's 10 years old the judge I was
like no no kid is coming in my court you
guys haven't been here for six and a
half years what's the issue like I don't
feel feel like I had so much supporting
evidence and I don't feel it was looked
at I
feel I feel like I was done like there's
what else can I do the only thing I can
do is come here and share my
story and um that's thank you for
listening well thank you very much I
appreciate it and I'm really sorry that
you have to be here doing this yeah but
I can either cry at home or I can try
and make a difference do you know how
many times I've cried this committee oh
my go pleas You Are Not
Alone are there any further
questions well thank you very much
than okay so that's it I don't have any
more pink cards thank you everyone I am
now closing the hearing on HB
1382 and that's that's a wrap for the
day
I don't want to take your only
copy so so she can you show me in here
where she where did she so but what I
want to know whoops hold
on
e